this is jocko podcast number 273
with echo charles and me jocko willink
good evening echo good evening
i was with the turks and we were heading
south
the chinese had entered the war a few
days before
they had kicked the ass of the entire
eighth army
and we were on the run we had descended
a
spur of the ridge and were crossing the
valley when we came to a village
everywhere you looked were the corpses
of slaughtered
americans one a captain of
infantry i had met back in fort lewis
was strung up by the wrist
between two buildings his feet not quite
touching the ground
he raised his head slightly and his lips
trembled
as he tried to speak his strength lay in
a pool of frozen blood beneath his feet
i leaned my rifle against the wall
and reached up to cut the ropes
water he breathed softly
then coughed once the air gurgling
through the blood in his throat
i had heard it before from the coal
miners
back in hermione it made no difference
whether i cut him down or not
he was dead
his chin sank to his chest and he swayed
lightly
like the thin frail branches of the
willow trees next to the cemetery back
home
the men captured with him were hanging
too
some between branches some in doorways
one between
two thick limbs of an ancient apple tree
they had all been butchered the same way
stripped
then strung up like christ on the cross
their stomachs had been sliced open and
their guts
pulled out to dangle down before them
blood flesh and guts were trampled in
the snow everywhere
the turks glided silently from body to
body
cutting each down and laying it to rest
a bright korean moon etched in silver
the horror
of the scene
i can hardly remember a time when i
didn't want to be in the service
both my brothers were in bud was a chief
torpedo men
in the north atlantic chuck the oldest
was an infantry company commander in
europe
bud was the more colorful storyteller
and the navy would have been my choice
hands down
except for hollywood
artillery barrages hand-to-hand combat
paratroopers the jungles errol flynn
in burma that was war
i was born to be an infantryman
and that right there is the opening of a
book called the making of a soldier
by lieutenant kearney lieutenant colonel
anthony herbert
and this is an incredible book and i've
been referencing it here and there as
i've been reading it
for the last few months
and it's actually two books there's
actually two books one is the book i was
just reading from called the making of a
soldier
the other is simply called soldier both
written by
lieutenant colonel anthony tony herbert
and i
first heard of these books a few months
ago i'd never heard of them before
and i spoke to the cadets at west point
and the colonel that hosted me by the
name of colonel pat howell
he's the director of the modern war
institute at west point
and after this event he emailed me
and and during the event i had mentioned
about
face and hackworth while i was talking
to the
to the cadets and colonel howell sent me
a photograph in this email
and this photograph that he sent was
a photograph of his copy of about face
and it was actually signed by
colonel hackwith and hackworth then the
inscription said to patrick
you come from a long line of great
warriors who led
by that adage
of looking after your men warmest
regards
hack and it turned out
that hackworth had worked for
colonel howell's grandfather in the army
and so colonel howe sent me a message
and he also sent me a message an
image of another book and and the book
that he sent me the image of us called
soldier
and colonel howell said this in the
email he said speaking of dave hackworth
i sent a pic of his autograph of my copy
and he had worked for my grandfather
years previously i've also sent a
picture of a very hackworth-like story
about a guy named tony herbert the book
is called
soldier he also was enlisted in the
korean war
got commissioned and then was a
battalion commander in vietnam
and had a prickly time with his chain of
command
he also worked for my grandfather back
in germany circa 1960.
so i mean i get that report right there
it's all i need to hear
i hunt down these books online
these two books one one soldier and and
then the other one
the making of a soldier
and i ordered them both and it's to me
okay well great i got another warrior
that i can try
and learn from pretty straightforward
but i should have paid more attention to
the statement
that herbert that this guy colonel
herbert had quote had a prickly time
with his chain of command in vietnam
this is actually a pretty significant
understatement and it makes
this whole story and the lessons learned
just not not quite as straightforward
a lot of controversy and and the whole
this whole story which is a combined
about a 600 pages of reading
between the two books
as i tried as i read these books
and this this way this story
comes out it's a pretty big elephant to
try and swallow
and i wasn't quite sure how to approach
the whole thing for for the podcast
i read the books and then i'm just kind
of stewing on them
because there's the whole thing there's
war and there's war crimes and there's
accusations and counter accusations and
there's good leadership and there's
batted leadership and it's all
it's all wrapped up around the story of
one of the most highly decorated
soldiers from the korean war
a man that you're gonna see how often
this guy's wounded over and over again
blown up hit with white phosphorus
shot and bayoneted
multiple times
so you have this completely heroic
individual
that is definitely a hack worth type
leader
and you see these heroic tendencies
eventually get caught up and put through
the ringer of
politics and ego and the bureaucratic
machine
and it just really makes it
a complex story and as i read the book
of the both of them
that there was lesson after lesson of
what to do and what not to do and what
to watch out for
and like i said because the vast range
of the story is hard for me to wrap my
head around it
and present it and figure out how to
present it and luckily i have a standard
operating procedure of what to do when
i'm facing a tough task
what you do is you put your rock on and
you start marching
and that's what we're going to do here
the life and times of
colonel anthony tony herbert and i'm
going to utilize both these
books and kind of bounce back and forth
to get some background on on herbert's
life
um to start with we're gonna go to his
second book which is
called soldier
so here we go both my brothers were
born well before me charles 15 years
earlier in jules paul
11. almost a different generation
a fact of life for which i never really
forgave them because when world war ii
came along
they both packed up and marched off
leaving me standing on the front porch
cursing the irrevocable fact that in
1941 in america there wasn't a great
demand for 10 year old fighting men
i cried too when they left not because
they were going to war and might not
come back
but because i couldn't go with them
my mother tried to comfort me the army
doesn't want you now
tony she said you've just got to learn
to understand rules are rules
but i neither could nor would all i
really knew for certain
was that one day above all other things
i wanted to be a soldier
and that somebody or something was
ruining my dream
so this guy comes out of the womb ready
to rock and roll as they say
and i'll tell you as i oh you're i get
into this early life
it's definitely a very cool description
of america in this time frame
both prior to world war ii when he's a
little kid and then as he gets a little
bit older
he says this guns were always an
integral part of my life
in the herbert family not because
we were great sportsmen or anything like
that but simply because we like to eat
and eating wasn't simple wasn't a simple
matter for a coal miner
and his family in those days the mines
were all my father had ever known
the day after day regimen of dust and
dirt and darkness and penny pinching in
poverty
with never enough pennies to pinch up
until
john l lewis and the united mine workers
came along in 1939 the most cash my
father
ever saw for one week's work was two
dollars
the rest of his compensation came in the
form of credit at the eureka store
where mr stahls the manager and dutiful
employee
of the mine would carefully match the
amount of purchases against the amount
of credits it inevitably worked out
at the end of the year that my father
and every other miner in town had bought
more than their credit allowed
all my life i heard my father and mother
worry about paying off the company store
before they died
their chief aim was to leave without
passing that particular debt
onto their children they lived in a
company-owned house
in a company-owned town in a
company-owned county
neither my father nor any other man who
worked in the mines
could quit how could they
the minds owned them
but none of us ever really felt poor
there were so many other families just
like us
that we had no standard of comparison
everybody had to struggle to make it
at least everybody with whom we had any
contact
and for all we knew the whole world
lived precisely
as we did there in harmony 40 miles from
pittsburgh
deep in the black heart of coal mine
country
different kind of lifestyle yes
if my father ever complained about the
grim cycles in his life
i never heard him
he was as steady as a clock up before
dawn walked to the mine
back home in the evening for a glass of
beer or two before supper and then to
bed
but with a wife and four children
charles and jules my two older brothers
plus our sister irene four years my
senior and me
there was never enough money never near
enough
and the income from his guide service
and i skipped ahead
he also like will guide hunters
sometimes
his income from the guide service
couldn't bridge the gap
he trapped muskrats and sold pelts to
montgomery ward and sears and roebuck
an average skin would bring about 1.75
an exceptionally good one would sell
for three dollars and although he
approached his trapping with all the
same skill and determination devoted to
his job at the mine and his hunting it
still wasn't enough
there were occasions when he would have
to trudge down to the welfare office
it was painful for him i knew he dreaded
every trip he had ever made down there
and when he came back
with the government commodities a bag of
rice a bag of raisins
a bag of cornmeal he had the look of a
man who had stood in a line of men going
nowhere
he was unusually grim and for days
afterwards
he would not be himself but somehow
quieter more withdrawn
i suppose the only comfort he had was in
knowing that he wasn't the only husband
and father
in harmony who was having trouble taking
care of his family
all of us went to whatever lengths were
necessary to get the job done
we made wine at home and sold or traded
it for essentials
charles took on an ice route
delivering the 25 pound and 50 pound
blocks up and down the street
we picked coal at the slate dump a
smoking mountain of coal waste
deposited by the mine just at the edge
of town it was about a quarter mile
across and three quarters of a mile long
all of the childhood images i have
retained one of the most vivid
is of that ebony heap rising above the
houses steaming and hissing like a
volcano
we would trudge up its crumbling sides
pick up pieces of slate
knock off knock the coal off and put it
in our burlap sacks that we carried
at the end of the day we piled our sacks
into a wheelbarrow and went downtown to
sell the call for a dime a sack
the slate pile was never one of my
favorite places there were cavernous
hollow pockets beneath its contours
and we had all heard of the two people
who had gone to the dump and disappeared
forever
into its black bowels
but somehow we survived
the town was one of several built around
a collection of mines that had attracted
not only the baltic immigrants but a lot
of scots and irishmen as well
sulphur creek a bright red steam fed
constantly
with a drain off from the mines
separated our town from limerick hill
the first of the others the social
systems
that were premised on that creek were as
rigid as though it were the berlin wall
still despite our differences i never
knew what they were
we shared one common bond the mines and
their wailing whistles
that shrieked out at the beginning and
end of the workers days
sounding for miles and miles through the
hills
and sometimes signaling the reality of
death
my uncle joe shearer my mother's oldest
sister's husband died in a cave-in
at the nearby barking mine when i was
about four years old
three or four other miners were also
killed in that cave-in
and i remember the sound of the whistles
it was always like that back then always
some accident or cave-in
that killed one or two or three men not
any major disaster
as the newspapers like to say and so it
was forgotten
and ignored by those who had the kind of
power that would have made some
difference in the condition of the minds
and the dangers faced by those who
worked in them
he goes on here he talks about the
church and he has a father kelly there
said i always loved father kelly
but i was never sure about the church he
was a kind old man who had been a hero
in world war one and had the medals to
prove it
according to my father he had been
gassed
at times he seemed very nervous about
being a priest and maybe that why he was
drinking a great deal he talks about
another guy named dr latimer
and look i'm i'm going into some detail
here
because as this story unfolds you've got
to try and
figure out where he's making decisions
from what
you know where where where is his
morality rooted
and it's very clear as you move through
this that there's people that
influence the way he thought another guy
that influenced the way he thought is a
guy named dr latimer
and this guy was you know like the local
doctor
and he kind of got to know him a little
bit
and one of the things he would do is
give him copies of national geographic
and again this is one of those things
where when you read this you think okay
it's when you look back when you when
you see the way the whole story unfolds
you look back you you think to yourself
okay this is interesting
he says it was doc i think who first
started impressing me with the idea
that wherever people live
they're essentially the same look at
these natives he would say
pointing at some bare-breasted folks
from australia or africa
they hunt just like you hunt tony and
just like your father and your brothers
the only difference is that they use a
bow and arrow
they bleed if they get cut and the
fathers and mothers
worry about their children and they all
worry about food and about dying
and they all want to live as long as
they can just like you tony
the doc never went to church somehow
that impressed me like my father
he seemed always to be what he was
never any phoniness around him or about
him
so that's again you can kind of see this
guy's developing a pretty strong moral
character
about other people and seeing other
people as people and
what the common ground is
talks more here about father kelly he
was a good priest good in the sense that
he deeply knew the people in his flock
he knew their poverty and their
hopelessness and their frequent
desperation and above all he knew how
absolutely necessary
it was that their individual family
incomes be supplemented
that's why he showed no reservations at
all about
doctoring baptismal certificates
in 1942 when i was 12 years old he
changed mine to make it read that i was
and thus allowed me to get a work permit
and start bringing home a little cash
for the family
he had done the same for my brothers i
was told and for almost anybody else in
town who had sons who were willing to
i work taken my first job when i was 10
along with
richard nadel the brother of a pretty
girl named
mary grace we worked on mueller's
farm right outside of town and every
morning at 4 30 rain or shine
mr mueller would come into town and pick
us up on his little truck we were paid
1.50 a week
and a gallon of raw milk and for that
we both drove tractors cut wheat dug
potatoes fed his cattle milked his cows
he knew what he was doing obviously that
wasn't helping much with the
family financial burdens and father
kelly's forgery was an absolute
necessitary
necessity so that so he had the like the
under the table job but you're not
getting paid very much so he gets this
doctored
birth certificate he goes out and gets a
job at this glass factory he goes into
some detail about that
he's he's working in a situation where
he's wearing a full asbestos
suit and you work he's working in a
place that's so
hot you're only allowed to work for 10
minutes and then it's 10 minutes break
and and it's not like these are uh
lenient labor laws this
it had to be so hot that you would like
die
if you don't get a break so then he he
does that job for a while he ends up at
the pennsylvania railroad he's making 85
cents an hour
and he's doing this job where once again
there's a 600 pound piston that's like
above you and you'd never be if it
happened to fall you were dead because
you couldn't hear anything
and he of course he liked football he
liked playing sports but he says here i
soon learned that the practice time
required for high school athletics ate
into the time i could spend in the field
with my hunting and my trapping
during games on saturday i would tie
hunting dogs to the bench and stash my
gun
beneath it while we played
during one of the during one of the
winters in my early teens the
cousters lost four of their children
in one swift stroke of fate
and once again the mind whistle told the
story to the neighboring communities
one of the older brother harry's harry
was a friend of mine
his two younger brothers and two sisters
were out one afternoon
playing on the frog ponds in the area
ponds created by the still drainage of
the mines
the near zero temperatures had frozen
the water to what the kids believed was
a safe depth
but the ice broke beneath them and one
by one the others plunged through and
drowned two
trying to effect a rescue with the
courage so typical of the area
all four dead
i had never seen harry cry before i
caught
his eye at stator's funeral home and his
tears
moved me to cry myself
again what just the fact that he's
talking about sort of this courage
and if you think about what your job is
what most people's jobs go into those
minds every day
he talks about another buddy of his and
it doesn't really
well he doesn't explain what happened
because he didn't know what happened but
somehow this kid got shot with a 22
caliber
like playing around or whatever
um he says he lived for some months but
then gangrene set in
and they brought his body back to her
her mini
the funeral said at st edwards where i
was an altar boy the priest
took the water shaker from me and began
to sprinkle its contents on the casket
and i remember that i stood there before
the altar trying to figure out at which
end
of the great metal box they'd place
joe's head
and which end his feet i never really
thought in terms of the dead as being
punished
it had always been a matter of living
getting their comeuppance
but that night my mother asked me to
pray for the soul of joe and for the
first time in my life
i did offer prayers on behalf of another
person
i never picked individual fights but i
never seem to have any trouble getting
into them
either i guess because i was larger than
most of the guys my age a lot of them
couldn't resist the challenge
i don't remember ever losing one
so we get a good background of the guy
we get a good feel of the situation it's
very tough hard work always behind the
eight ball financially
but still nonetheless tight community
forward a little bit while i was getting
started as an adolescent
my brothers were fighting the war chuck
became an infantry officer and a company
commander in italy
and bud a navy man served as chief
torpedo man
aboard a destroyer that prowled the
north atlantic their letters were never
any aid or comfort to me vicarious
combat like books and movies and
teleplays
had never been my cup of tea
i hadn't quite recovered from their
abrupt departure from hermine
and their subsequent location in places
with exotic names when they came home
with medals on their chests and war
stories
to tell the old man on the front porch
in the spring of 1944
that's what i wanted and i wanted it
badly i still wanted to be a soldier and
i knew exactly how i could do it the
military's rules be
damned the phony baptismal certificate
father kelly had worked for me
had worked up for me was the key
actually i was
already getting some advice from people
at work about registering for the draft
they thought i was 18 years old and i
saw no reason to disappoint them
i went over to erwin with my work permit
in hand and told mrs
gangaware at the draft office that i'd
just forgotten about it and needed to
register she looked at me as if i were a
low-life son of a [ __ ] who was trying
to sneak out of my duty as an 18 year
old american citizen
actually i was a 14 year old teenager
american citizen that was trying to do
my best to sneak into my duty
i'd like to say it was all my idea but i
can't remember
whether it was me or my friend tony
spazzali
so him and tony spazali decide they're
going to go enlist
they they catch her they hitch a ride to
till they get outside of pittsburgh
once they get outside of pittsburgh we
walk the rest of the way to the u.s post
office in downtown pittsburgh
where we both joined the us marines this
kid's 14.
the next day the train tony and i were
riding southward
through virginia towards paris island
south carolina
it was halted in some backwoods town and
we were taken off by a man who
identified himself only as a federal
officer we were both impressed if
disappointed
when we when we arrived back at the
pittsburgh
depot mr gressman our high school
principal was waiting and took us home
my father only shook his head but my
mother was glad to see me and smothered
me with forgiveness
i went back to my traps and my school
and my job and the railroad
the very next day i wasn't finished
however i was only waiting
fast forward a little bit three years
later now he's actually the right age
he goes to unless he's 17 years old goes
to the marine corps recruiting office
and gets told the quote is full
because by the way the war is over like
the war had been over
so he missed world war ii and he turned
17 right cool
sorry we ain't got nothing for you so he
gets told by the marine corps recruiter
sorry nothing for you
and then at that moment a man wearing
the us army's 11th airborne patch on his
shoulder sauntered into the marine's
office
and noticed my quandary hey kid you want
to be a paratrooper he's he asked what's
that i inquired
you jump out of planes and fight he said
and i joined
period end of story we got you
a week later in the early morning of may
9th 1947 i got up to say goodbye to my
folks my father who rose at 4 30 every
morning
of his life except sundays was sitting
at the kitchen table when i came
downstairs already dressed and ready to
leave my mother was puttering quietly
around the stove
and the large white enamel cabinet
preparing lunch for my father to take to
the mine
i sat down and poured a cup of coffee
into a metal cup
i suppose my father felt it was
absolutely necessary that he gave me
some parting advice
although he like i had no idea what
being a paratrooper meant
but it was good advice as i recall it
went something like this
the uniform doesn't mean you're a
soldier
whatever you do don't get disgusted
stick with it
like you stick with it here at home
remember what your brothers did
nobody ever quit it won't be any harder
than hunting
than waiting in the creek in the winter
time
nothing is as hard as just getting
started
it's like in the coal mines every step
takes care of itself
then we walked out together my mother
didn't cry i wouldn't have expected it
to stoicism is a virtue
that a coal miner's wife develops i
never remember my mother as a young
woman
not that day or any other and when my
wife is 60 years old she will be younger
than my mother
was at 30. my mother waved from the
porch as my father and i
descended the 20 steps to the road
his ride to the mine came by and they
disappeared into the darkness
i walked to the eureka store caught a
bus to erwin took a train to pittsburgh
and then on the morning of may 10th 1947
i arrived at fort dix new jersey
i recall that moment as among the
happiest in my life
the moment i stepped off that train
and knew i was on my way to my dream
i was going to be a soldier
so we kind of get an idea of what we're
dealing with here i think that's
some important background to grab
and then um
we're going to go back to this other
book so we're going to go back to the
other book the making of a soldier
and what's what's
what's interesting about this is he
originally wrote this book
um he originally wrote this book so so
the the the big book
the soldier book came out i think 19 i
think he wrote it came out 1973 or
something like that
maybe a little bit later but this other
book
he had written it he had originally
written a book called conquest of
nowhere it was just about his experience
in korea
and he wrote that in 1954
and he was young when he wrote it and he
explains this
in the kind of the the preface to this
book he explains he was young he had a
co-author
the co-author kind of kind of ran with
it a little bit
more than he did and so it ended up
really not reflecting what he had been
through
so he rewrote this book later so we're
picking this up where
he's at basic training so in basic we
were interviewed
periodically for school assignments my
choice was infantry
and i kept asking for it i was advised
each time that only an
idiot would want to go infantry but
there's no way to discourage me
although i got pretty mad at being told
that a soldier who wanted to fight was
crazy
one day i was about to tell the captain
and a couple of lieutenants just what i
thought of
leaders who attempted to sell men on
every profession in the army except the
one it had been created for
when my friend bob heisey took me aside
look herb
don't let the bastards get to you if you
don't accept a school they're gonna have
to let you go infantry
but frankly i think you're nuts he was
right not that i was nuts
but that if i held out they would have
to let me go
infantry i did and they did
so after basic because it goes through
basic training some stories about that
in here and
obviously i'm fast forwarding through a
bunch of this stuff you have to get
these books to get the full details
after basic i cooled my heels for a
couple weeks with the second infantry
division fort lewis washington until my
papers were processed
then i was sent to jump school and was
graduated as an infantryman
and a paratrooper i served a year and a
half was discharged
and returned to finish school at
sec wickley township high in her mini
no one went anywhere in the us army
without a high school diploma so i
earned mine
then reenlisted in the 82nd airborne
division at fort bragg
four months later while i was studying
radio repair
at fort monmouth the north koreans
invaded south korea i was shaving when
my friend
harry burst into the latrine with news
that the united states was going to
provide combat assistance to south korea
my head whipped around and i sliced a
notch on my chin that passed for a
dimple for a good two years
harry and i talked it over we made our
decision then we made our pitch
we asked to be released from school
early to go to korea
the commanding officer laughed korea he
explained was a zero a big nothing
our troops in japan were quite capable
of handling things over there and he
said it would all be over before our
request could even be processed
he's crazy i later insisted to harry it
can't be
i wasn't going to be cheated again i
tried to go over his head it was useless
i tried to flunk out of the course it
was impossible the only way was to
graduate so i bore down i took night
classes i applied myself
i was gonna get out i was going to get
out of the signal core
completely i was going to get out of the
82nd i was going to get out of the
united states i was going to get to
korea
and i was going to get back into
infantry as an infantryman and a fight
in the war
and he makes a good attempt
he makes a good attempt he makes it
happen he graduates from the school
and now he is on a troop transport which
took ten days to get to japan those were
the longest days of my life on the
eighth i was assigned kp
refused to pull it and got busted from
private first class
back to private it didn't matter i was
on my way to war
and i wasn't about to arrive with dish
pan
hands besides who the hell cared whether
i got there as a pfc or a private
he's just full on man he is full on
we were briefed by some of the evacuated
veterans of korea who were being used to
give us the real scoop before we went in
some of it was [ __ ] [ __ ] most of
it was true
a sergeant a vet of both world war ii
and korea told it best
winter is coming he informed us
most likely you will find it more severe
than any winter you have ever seen
it's high rugged country and bitter cold
and you'll be out there in the weather
24 hours a day for months
he explained how the enemy were they
were not cowards he said
they were well armed and they could
fight
yeah sure sarge some smart ass heckled
from the back of the auditorium
tell us a war story his glance swept
over us
i'm not gonna tell you any war stories
you'll have your own soon enough
and some of you won't live long enough
to tell them
three days later i was sitting ashore
with orders assigning me to the 20th air
ground
signal liaison in busan as far south as
you could go
but i hadn't come to korea to repair
radios and i wasn't about to sit out the
war in busan
there had there were plenty of guys
around who would be happy with those
orders they didn't need me
i went up to see the captain and
explained that i was an infantry
paratrooper and i expected to go to the
187th airborne regimental combat team
or back to the second infantry division
both were in country
he scarcely heard me he said what i'd
been hearing ever since i had joined the
army
impossible i was humiliated and furious
and stormed back to where my gear lay
piled on the wet ground
i was surrounded by troops who had been
wounded and who were now returning to
their units
artillery pounded to the north i wasn't
going south
the next day when they loaded trucks
aimed north i picked one
with second division on its bumper and
leaped aboard
i was a wall in korea
you know what a wall means right absent
without leave
so he's just got this cushy job
repairing radios
and he randomly selects a vehicle
and jumps on board
you think that's like you go that's
that's kind of crazy well look at this
the truck was a mixed bag of vets and
replacements from a half a dozen dozen
different countries a korean was driving
i soon discovered that i was the only
american aboard i also learned from one
of the koreans who spoke english better
than i did that the truck belonged not
to the u.s second infantry division
but to the republic of korea army second
infantry division
so i first saw combat in a korean
division
but at least i was in battle
and look there's i could
i could easily just turn this into an
audio book and read the entire freaking
thing
like i it's there's so much
there's so much interesting things that
happen you you you kind of have to read
it yourself
and i apologize i don't want to do a
full audio book of this
because he i'm reading these things and
i'll be like well i i can't read the
whole book and then you read something
crazy
this could never happen nowadays right
now obviously no okay
like i mean i guess i guess it kind of
could it kind of could actually
kind of circumstances hey man you're in
country
you know uh you could you could you
could get away with a lot you get away
with a lot because
they don't have they don't have you know
you could you could kind of make things
happen right
just like you know you're sneaking into
a concert you kind of act like you know
what you're doing and you kind of walk
past the doorman like you're going to
you got some tasks that you're supposed
to do yeah no no one says anything to
you
yeah so you know you throw your name hey
can you put me on that manifest to get
this flight up to baghdad
you know somebody be like where are you
from i was i'm from a sealed team that's
supposed to be up there
you know name's willing
what happened oh and i i was late my you
know i i was
uh my kid was sick and i got here late
i'm just trying to get up with my unit
and they're like
they're just going to hook you up right
right yeah that's the problem
when we were talking to tilt yeah it was
either tilt or it was
it might have been dick thompson who was
like
if you volunteered to go to vietnam's
like yeah cool yeah you're
you're in it wasn't like hey can i
please go
oh yeah you want to go to nom cool oh
you want to go to special forces cool
you want to you want to go to you want
to go to sock cool no problem
yeah so it's sort of a little bit of
that
still like nowadays i think you could
get away with some of this it would be a
little bit trickier
yeah many occasional strap hangers roll
around country
doable though yeah it's surprisingly
influential when someone just sounds
like and looks like they know what
they're talking about
hey man you know what you know how you
you know you know how you know what
someone's rank is
they have a little patch that's velcroed
onto their thing so
yeah freaking andy stumpf talking about
that any stuff would like
make himself a make himself a lieutenant
commander and he's a
he'd make himself four ranks above what
he actually was
yeah so i mean yeah and i guess right i
mean it's one of those things where it's
like yeah if they chose to look into it
and it's like yeah they could eventually
find out but if you're just
you know raising no suspicion because
you look like you know what you're
talking about
like you're not going to look into every
little thing that happens to you you
know especially there's a war going on
you're like oh you're a replacement cool
yeah you're not like let me see your
paperwork yeah oh by the way when they
ask for your paperwork you say oh
yeah you got blown up yeah
and it's not like you're trying to do
something that a normal person would be
thinking is advantageous for you
it's not like you're saying hey i need
to get on a plane did you go to japan
right right
people are probably saying hey what do
you mean what do you need to go to japan
yeah
what's he talking about that's not
happening but if you're saying hey i
want to go to the front lines
yeah hey and you're going to see his
whole tour basically he's awol
he's awol this whole tour just and he
does exactly what you said he kind of
shows up and
gets with the company and starts working
so
he's in a way it's almost like a crazy
irony where he's awol but he's awol
because he's not a wall
you see him saying he's like yes yeah
he's
he's b-wall like i'm going to get some
he's get some wall whatever that is
yeah you could you could get i think you
get away with some of it i mean
i know that we definitely did some let
me give you an example we did things
that were
not normal you know maybe not a fish
you know not official maneuvers yeah you
know my
my seabees so i had seabees that which
is construction battalion so they're
navy guys that
do construction and they've got a really
awesome historical um story
in that they would build airfields in
world war ii and they did and there's
part of the
part of the underwater demolition teams
that use some of that experience
from the seabees so there's a there's a
connection there anyways
seabees are cbs the cvs that worked for
me
they did some stuff that was not above
that was not 100 let's say authorized
right for instance we need a piece of
equipment we need a piece of gear we
need
a bunch of lumber to build something
basically my seabees would figure out
how to get that stuff that we needed
and you know they might be trading
stakes or whatever
captured weapons or whatever just
whatever random things
and here you go yep make stuff work so
there's there's definitely
it's a little bit more it's wild west
right yeah you ever heard
like iraq or afghanistan described
always the wild west out there
yeah i hear people say that it takes a
little while for the administrative
things to catch up so when it's when
you're waiting for administrative things
to catch up there's some shady
activities happening you're making some
things happen who's the guy
and there's a movie about it he was like
a young kid
and he'd go and he'd be a pilot and he'd
really like
do stuff like stuff would be like i
don't know the name of the movie but i
know what you're talking about but i
never watched it either but
would he like get and fly a plane yeah
yeah he would apparently the story i
didn't see the movie either but
he i remember seeing uh no it was an
interview he was on like a
like a podcast yeah and he's older or
whatever but he was saying like yeah
his main thing would you just act like
you know what you're doing that's all
you got to do always a good one
and so he could be like this young kid
even though like straight up like
someone that young will never be a pilot
like it just doesn't
you know happen like that and he'd just
act like he knew what he was doing and
they'd be like yeah cool
that's why they call it a con man right
because you have to have this confidence
this level of confidence
so he's got a level of confidence here
just to jump on with a bunch of north
koreans
the reason that i went off on this
tangent about not reading everything is
because
he jumps in he's in combat with these
guys he says
uh uh the first guy i was sure
that i had shot bounded into the air
then dropped over a ledge before us
it was my first sure kill but i felt
neither revulsion nor a sense of power
just indifference
i had had more compassion for rabbits
and deer a guy with a rifle in his hands
coming to kill me
did nothing to stir my sympathy
subsequent years of combat in korea and
vietnam served only confirm and
strengthen that feeling
ten minutes later i was out of
ammunition this is his first scenario
10 minutes later i'm out of ammunition
everyone else on my side had already
taken off
so i picked up a wounded korean and
helped him back to where i had joined
the unit
now look what happens he he he finds a
jeep
with four american gis and just kind of
rolls with them because he doesn't want
to be
he's with koreans with people that
aren't speaking
there's a few people that speak english
but most of them aren't and then
he jumps in with them um ends up going
to this replacement depot
and load he gets loaded onto a box car
that's
that's heading south and then a couple
days later he ends up where he's
supposed to be
okay so a couple days later we were near
enough for me to make my move oh he gets
to busan so he gets back to busan
because he's with the korean unit he
doesn't want to be the korean unit so he
goes back to busan to figure out like
okay how can i get with some americans
he gets back there
and a couple days later we were near
enough for me to make my move i stole a
jeep
and drove over to the 23rd they were
preparing for
to jump off for the yalu river a push
north
designed to end the war headed home was
the modded motto home by christmas
macarthur promised rumor had it that the
7th
infantry division and the marines were
already rolling north
the rocks already have more men on the
yalu
on the yelu than the chinese on the
mainland to put it together
someone swore hell it's as good as over
i felt a pain in my heart
but what the hell a short war is better
than none besides life is full of
spreads
so he steals a jeep to go and again
right this guy's just
getting after it uh the temperature
plummeted
to 20 below again
i'm trying to figure out what to read
but you read you see that the
temperature's 20 below like let's make
sure
everybody knows extra equipment and
ammunition were issued
we began to feel a fever for conquest we
were going to end it the big attack was
on
not by us but by the chinese 1 million
strong they came at us
across the yalu river out of manchuria
surrounded by more than 30 full
divisions our attack
turned into a route
so then this happens so he's this
they're starting to kind of get
beat up and sergeant comes off and says
we got to get more troops up here the
turks are somewhere off close to the
east
do you know where they are sarge i don't
even know where we are
he ignored it well i know where they're
supposed to be
but i'd hope maybe you know for sure he
dropped a finger on my shoulder i've got
to send you after them
i don't have anyone to spare it's
another lesson of war if you don't
belong to the unit you can be spared so
he's just tagging along with these guys
and so the sergeant's like okay well i
need somebody to go do something it's
you
sure i'll go i heard myself volunteer
that was all
he didn't know any more about the turks
than i did if i found them okay if i
didn't that was okay too
two hours late later i located their
lead element they were still heading
north
looking for more chinese which said just
about all there is to say about them
every other unit was heading south
running from the chinese while the turks
were moving north looking for chinese
and the chinese were desperately trying
to avoid them i couldn't talk to the
turks and they couldn't talk to me i
tried to get across what i wanted but it
was useless
they had their orders attack north night
closed in
and i stayed so he's supposed to go
figure out what they're doing
and and he can't even communicate with
them to get them to do what he needed
them to do
so he stays with them for a while then
he decides on fast forward he decides
he's going to leave and go back and at
least tell him hey this is where the
turks are
i don't speak their language and what do
you want me to do next
and in order to leave he heads off to
the north he thinks it's going to be the
best way to go
and here we go back to the book i looked
ahead and spotted about 200 chinese
coming across the valley
not more than 100 yards out i dropped
down behind some rocks and fallen
timbers and stretched out on my belly in
the snow
recalling the dead captain that's what i
opened up with
i eased my rifle off safe i wasn't about
to be taken alive they came straight up
the finger toward me and passed i was
safe i was ready to move again
i put my hands down to push myself up
when all hell broke loose
the turks had opened up with everything
they had and chinese swarmed back down
the hill toward me
i was halfway to my feet it was too late
to drop back down and i couldn't just
stand there
i spun the rifle around and opened up on
three or four nearest to me
weapons flew in the air and bodies went
sailing past me ass over heels
i snatched up one of their burps and
squeezed the trigger a long
sharper rip rent the air and more bodies
tumbled by as fast as i emptied one
weapon i scooped up another
i had him by the balls i could fired
anything in any direction
they couldn't fire without hitting their
own troops running and milling around in
confusion
some headed back up the hill and the
turks opened up again
when they came back down i dropped
another couple dozen suddenly it fell
silent it was no time for me to move i
got back down and waited
at first light the turks sent a patrol
to see what the score was
between us we had accounted for almost
my foxhole buddy convinced them that i
had gone out after the entire group
alone
and i became an archidouche their
brother
later when i stood before their
president the only foreign soldier ever
to receive the turkish equivalent
of the congressional medal of honor
so now now he's in position with the
turks
and here we go again and i'm probably
going to be saying that a lot as we read
through this here we go again
they're in position and [ __ ] just gets
crazy
the major assault came from the west and
it wasn't too swift since we had the sun
at our back
some men fought some just froze but the
turks rose as one man
with fixed bayonets and met the charge
head-on about
20 yards out from the column flanks
steel clashing against steel
screams of pain and terror intermingling
but not a sound from the turks
a turk private who i came to know well
and who later died
slashed across the faces of three
chinese with one great sweep of his
blade
another a master sergeant who would
later visit my home in the states as a
hero of his nation
and as an honored guest of ours gutted
two more at my side
they loved it but the chinese i saw
already had no stomach for it
they routed quickly and fell back
abandoning their dead and wounded
the wounded the turks finished off they
gave no
quarter and asked none
by the way just fyi just so everyone
knows we're talking about bayonet
battles jumping ahead a little bit here
now they're in a column so they've
they've
kind of they've kind of been roughed up
and even though they've done some hard
fighting
they're heading south they got lots of
casualties they're in rough shape he's
back with americans now
as dark descended we saw chinese troops
perch like buzzards on the heights
around us
our column froze to a halt ammo was low
there was no rash in handout the few men
who had c-rats
mostly passed them to the wounded with
no wire for setting up a defense the
column had to move
a truck passed close to me and i fell
behind it letting
my ass drag a little suddenly my feet
flew out from under me and i cracked my
chin on the ice i bound up fast like a
novice boxer
embarrassed by a sudden unexpected
knockdown in the first round
my hands were sticky with blood i
glanced up and saw it
sluicing from under the tailgate of the
truck load of wounded and dead before me
and freezing on the surface of the road
i remembered running behind my brother's
ice delivery truck as a kid watching
water drip
out as the ice melted in the summer sun
what a waste of water
then it hit me war what a waste of blood
glancing back into the darkness at the
hills crawling with chinese
i realized that sometimes the
alternatives were worse so i
straightened myself
up 14 miles wasn't that far two men came
beside me in the darkness
one of them had one arm gone the other
both
they needed space in one of the trucks
myself and another soldier climbed
aboard and sifted through the wounded
for the dead we unloaded eight bodies
and laid them at the side of the road
helped the two wounded climb aboard then
dropped back again behind the truck
word came back again keep the column
moving or stop in place and die
so like i said they are they're in tough
shape as they're as they're extracting
in this situation
and again they he explains how they end
up
there but i can't i'm not going to read
not reading the whole book
a feeling of confidence and well-being
washed over me
i'd make it and so would most of the
others if they'd fight
we were breaking through some men were
beginning to rally
one when one truck driver bought the
farm someone else jumped in to take up
the slack
the column was moving it was make
contact pull back regroup
fight again and again but we were moving
many died needlessly tanks and trucks
plowed over them in the dark in
confusion
crushing dozens beneath wheels and
tracks the sounds of battle
and the powerful roar of engines drowned
out the screams
in the light of a flare i saw a man's
face frozen in horror
his mouth open in a soundless scream as
he went under the treads of a patent
tank
it was unavoidable and it was ghastly
three men were stretched out beside the
road white phosphorus
searing into their dead flesh an
incoming round struck halfway between us
and i hit the dirt
when i raised up they had disappeared
and a small crater hollowed the snow
where they had been
more artillery followed and i dove into
a hole made by an earlier round
there was another guy in there
go ahead you yellow bastard shoot me he
screamed
i still had dirt in my eyes i'm not a
yellow bastard i fired back
and i'm not gonna shoot you he was an
[ __ ] i figured
still brushing dirt from my eyes look i
said carelessly
meaning god damn it can't you see
i can't i can't he sob i can't see
anything
my eyes cleared and i saw his face a
massive searing
white phosphorus he might have been
one of the three i had thought was dead
or someone else who'd been hit in the
same
by the same round i scooped up chunks of
ice and snow and tried to clean it clean
his face
i led him out of the hole and over to a
medic
the medic lifted him onto the truck and
began to tend to to his injury
before the driver threw into gear and
lurched back into the column
i was still watching and wishing him
well when the truck took a direct hit
and disappeared
my throat was on fire i needed water i
reached out and broke off an icicle from
a passing truck
i stuck the end in my mouth and sucked
on it
it was sticky dirty and salty
it was frozen blood
it dropped from my hands i moved out
farther on to the flank again deeper
into the darkness
only a candy ass really needed water
just before first light i ambled toward
the head of the column and attached
myself to the lead unit
we came upon a unit that had gone before
us all of them dead
and many disemboweled like the men in
the village
a young lieutenant lay in a ditch with
his leg blown off above the knee
i tourniqueted it and loaded him onto a
passing tank with some other wounded
already aboard
a couple of hours later i found him
alongside the road with a bullet between
his eyes
the back of his head was gone and his
brains were splattered all over his vest
we attacked some more took some more
casualties took our wounded
and mostly left our dead behind us
we had lost 3 000 men in one day of the
000 remaining in the division
so eventually
they make it back and he gets
shipped to he gets assigned once again
to a rear unit and and
they're probably trying to take care of
him thinking this guy just went through
all this hell
and he requested to get transferred like
no i want to go to a front line unit and
what do they say they say that's
impossible
so he waited two days slung his rifle
and went back on a wall
and reported to a replacement unit
handling hospital returnees
i teamed up with a couple of men from
the 38th and returned to the unit
then on down to its second battalion
at battalion headquarters we were asked
which company we were from this is what
you're talking about
so he gets a battalion headquarters not
a battalion that he's even a part of
and they say which company are you from
and he says e company
i said and was loaded on the back of a
deuce in half and delivered at company
headquarters
i was assumed to be a replacement from
stateside and was turned over to dave
bernstein
a wonder from brooklyn whom i came to
cherish
you see that bridge up there we're going
to have to cross he asked yes
well we've crossed it at least four
times already two times south two times
north
i noticed him studying me out of the
corner of his eye they'll
they'll more than likely shoot us back
across it again tonight he glanced at
his watch
usually the [ __ ] hits the fan about 10
30.
they lay on the artillery for about 15
minutes
and then follow up with takasan chinks
takasan
that means a lot he studied me when he
said it
i felt myself flush come off it man i'm
no damn rookie
i made it to coonery with this outfit
he brought me up short you were at
coonery that's right what outfit who the
hell knows i was a radio man
i was a radio repairman i lied i didn't
have time to explain being awol
so he meets these guys this this easy
company here
uh bernstein signaled again now he's now
he's with these guys
and this scene as he read this it just
uh
gives you that i had to read this part
just so you get a kind of a
a sense of sense of
of who he's with and who these guys are
so he shows up
bernstein signaled and i stood up and
followed him into one of the huts
inside it was a little casino the mud
walls were covered with tapestries and
silk blankets e company had liberated
when they moved into the town
there was a small fire burning in the
fireplace
the mud fireplace there were
three-fifths of whiskey
on a small shelf and five half-empty
bottles in front of five soldiers
playing poker on a silk covered table in
the middle of the room
one of the men a sergeant kept calling
for bug
that's bugs hoover he's always calling
for the bug
aces straights and flushes bernstein
explained
he introduced me to the to the men with
whom i would serve until i left korea or
until they died or captured
some stood up and shook hands others
just nodded we watched for a bit
then left what are their jobs i asked
call me dave he said
mcpherson's the platoon sergeant used to
be an 82nd airborne i think
we kid him about the time he went awol
came back
and the old man said he'd never be a
soldier that was in the states
in four months he's been here he's gone
from pfc to master
he was the same old man who promoted him
max tough
but he's a hell of a good guy crandall's
a squad leader he hates war
and he hates the army but he fights
billy joe buckholtz is a rifleman a pfc
from atlanta
he's kind of new here too brinson's a
draftee
he's got kids one of them signed some of
his letters
though i don't believe he's even old
enough for school brynson's a bar man
bugs is a goddamn tiger he does anything
and everything that needs doing
sometimes he's a squad leader sometimes
he's a platoon sergeant he's everywhere
and anywhere
wherever there's gooks if you're a
fighter you'll like him and he'll like
you
if you're not stay the hell out of his
way
who's got the squad i'm assigned to i
asked king
forgot to mention he's a good joe too
hell they all are he said flinging up
his arms no sense in trying to say who
is and who isn't
he looked thoughtful the amazing thing
is the age average is less than 21
and that's including the world war ii
vets so there's a little introduction to
the guys
says the chinese didn't attack that
night but neither did we bugs lost his
ass at poker
10 years after errol flynn in burma i
was an honest to god infantrymen
i felt damn good i slept well
so uh well here we go god they just roll
they just roll you know the uh
you ever heard that adage i'm sure i've
said it here before that
war is a lot of waiting yeah there
is not waiting in this book there's very
little
because every time he seems like he's
going to have to wait he just goes hey
awol and finds
out he's fighting no time to win yeah
late the next afternoon we were briefed
by the company commander
still later we were briefed by our
platoon leader lieutenant
malinowski i was to go on patrol he said
he was sorry to have to send me out on
my first full day in the platoon but no
sweat
no real sweat he assured me it was only
a listening post at 1800 hours dave
sours crandall tate a guy called
self-propelled that's that's one of the
top nicknames i've ever heard in my life
the guy's name is self-propelled
freaking legit
uh he had come to e-company from an
artillery self-propelled gun unit so his
name was self-propelled
and myself were briefed by king who
would lead
we're gonna we're going a bit north for
tonight to lp5
nothing big there shouldn't be any
trouble we'll lay low and listen
we've all been out here before except
for herbert he glanced at me
all you have to do herbert is listen and
watch for unannounced company okay
okay i replied he continued briefing and
made it
simple clear and complete
it's kind of crazy right simple clear
and complete that's that's my
definition my definition is simple clear
and concise
and this one is simple clear and
complete
we moved out later each of us knew
exactly what was expected of him
and everyone else in the patrol so there
you go that's a just a beautiful
briefing
everybody knew what was expected of
themselves and of everyone else on the
patrol
these men were all business he goes on
the field now all these men were all
business no scuffing about
no talk no [ __ ] so these guys are
squared away
and fast forward a little bit these
patrols continue he briefs on some of
these patrols what they're like what's
going on
uh the weather is getting even colder
the the frontline positions
start to stabilize a little bit
now and it fast forward to a point
they're on
the e company easy company is in a
position they're on like the knob of a
hill
and we'll go to the book the moon rose
full and bright and the hills to the
north glowed in sharp relief
a trip flare rocketed into the sky from
the base of the hill before us and burst
like a bomb of light across the heavens
we could see the enemy a line of gray
white ghosts
floating forward over the snow about 250
yards away
the flare drifted in its shoot across
our entire front
shadows climbing back around us as it
disappeared then went out
hold fire hey easy company
why don't you go home this is home you
[ __ ] go back to china
someone yelled right back still neither
side fired
that's freaking crazy right they're
calling you by your company name
come down and fight someone on the other
side blew a bugle
and like a cavalry charge they swarmed
up the hill
the moon came out from behind the clouds
and lit up a sea of humanity racing over
the bright snow
toward us they picked up speed it was
the bonsai charge of the japanese in
world war ii
all over again we waited for their front
ranks to hit the 75-yard line
and squeezed our triggers nothing
happened
a few muffled chinks our weapons
were frozen firing pins immobile
immovable piss on them
someone said and word came down the line
we pissed on them
and it worked the urine melted the ice
and the troops all along the line began
to fire
men shifted positions to fill where
individual weapons had not been pissed
on yet i ended up in a hole with a
soldier from third platoon
herbert i said by way of introduction
john's he replied without looking up
i was i took up a firing position and he
continued to work on his rifle
a second later he dropped down beside me
and jerked two quick shots into
advancing troops
good he said now let's drive the little
bastards back to china
i didn't know where john's was from or
where he was going but he had style
yeah i said let's do that the other men
in the line apparently felt the same way
we broke the assault at more than 50
yards and drove them back down the hill
to lick their wounds
a kid to our right clambered out of his
hole and started down the back side of
the hill
mcpherson was on him like a cat where
the hell do you think you're going he
asked
to the aid station the guy answered i've
got the chills kid
mack told him it's 30 below zero we've
all got the chills get back in that hole
i'm going back to battalion the kid
shouted almost crying
i'm freezing mack leveled his carbine
get back in your hole i don't have time
to argue
his fingers squeeze the slack from the
trigger get back in that [ __ ] hole
now the kid turned and with
head hanging moved off in the dark
we heard the thud of his boots as he
jumped back down into his hole
the bugles sounded again this time they
came up the hill in battalion strength
but this time all of our weapons worked
whoever had come up with the piss
technique deserved a congressional medal
of honor
we piled the bodies on top of one
another all along the front
my bar began to overheat and the smell
of cordite and urine
seared my nostrils flares popped
overhead again
lighting up the slope below and the
valley beyond
the chinese were everywhere like ants
they were coming in in waves
it was a standard tactic with them the
first wave was light it was meant to
draw fire so they could note
and pinpoint our positions of our
automatic weapons
the second wave was to knock out our
and overrun us or at least wear us down
so the third wave could finish us off
this time however three waves couldn't
be enough
and they seem to know it as well as we
did they had come prepared
their leaders were pros and seldom
underestimated
who they were up against they knew that
any unit prepared to pay the price could
overrun any position
these guys always came ready to pay that
price john's was killed in the third
assault
i laid his rifle in ammunition beside my
own on the edge of the position
then as an alter as an afterthought i
extracted his bayonet from his scabbard
and fixed it to his rifle i was ready i
tucked my boots beneath
his body to keep to keep them warm but
he was already cold
it was going to be a long night by the
fifth wave
the chinese had paid the price the
hillside
before us was littered with their dead
and wounded
we had sustained about 40 percent
casualties ourselves
ammunition was almost non-existent the
artillery had ceased to fire
in our support the last of our wounded
were already on their way
toward the rear walking wounded carrying
the dead
and incapacitated
the sixth wave hit and the order came
down to fall back to cover the wounded
i leaped out of my position no one had
come by to pick up john's i checked his
body
the round had caught him smacking the
forehead above his left eye
the back of his head was gone i slung
his rifle over my shoulder
locked his cartridge belt above my own
and joined the rest of the men
at the base of the hill we came to a
road which led back
across the bridge our battalion
commander colonel skelden
was rounding up units and reorganizing
them for a counter-attack
his driver was besides a trailer tagged
onto his jeep passing out ammo
when we were ready skeldon led us back
up the hill
he had done so efficiently and so
quickly that we caught the six wave not
yet ready to defend
within minutes we were back in our
positions consolidated and ready
first light was breaking and the chinese
pulled back
we gathered up the rest of our dead
john's went back down the hill
in a mattress cover sours and tate
dead went along with him the chinese had
outnumbered us
at least ten to one they had weapons and
guts
they had been willing to pay the price
but so would we
you know when they get to wave number
five
you're thinking wow and that's not
it here comes wave number six
and and and the reason that you can't
stay there is because you're out of
ammunition
40 percent loss had cut us down far
below combat strength we were ordered
into reserve
reserve it's a powerful word in a combat
zone it's a full night's sleep in a
couple days
you're almost certain to live through
it's time to catch up to get your
bearings
bearings and a time to find out how the
war is going for the rest of the
division for the rest of the army
since a man in combat doesn't have much
opportunity to look around him
we had fine weather the sun broke
through and the frozen
earth became a quagmire replacements
came in and were assigned to fill the
gaps
day after they arrived e-company went
into heavy combat training
we reviewed attack formations and
procedures defenses
withdrawals marches and counter-attack
we practiced until
every one of them understood what was
expected of them under all conditions
we laid down the standard operating
procedures which had worked for us
in the conditions of this war good
training cuts losses and we intended to
cut our losses to a minimum
we trained and we trained hard
we got a few supplies by airdrop
sometimes those came in with mail from
home
and all training would grind to a halt
mail was considered a morale builder
personally i disagreed i didn't write
much and didn't expect to get a letter
i got them of course but they didn't
mean much to me home was too far away
what happened an easy company 38th
infantry regiment was more important
if you kept your mind on where you were
the war was easier
if you let your thoughts drift to things
that no longer existed for you
then you were in trouble letters i read
quickly sometimes
skipping entire paragraphs and i got rid
of them
packages i broke open immediately and
shared their contents on the spot
i consumed my portions on the on the
hoof
and forgot them it's good advice man
it's
good advice all right i was like you
know
my like i was in a platoon and it was
before the wars just like a normal
deployment
boxing to do and uh i remember there was
a guy you know like you know
one of guys was married you know had a
girlfriend or whatever and i remember
seeing him he was just
he was staring at a picture of her
and i just remember thinking that he was
torturing himself right
and driving himself crazy and it made no
sense to me
and i remembered that i was like a young
you know single guy at the time so i
made a mental note that that's not a
good way that's not a good
thing to do right
fast forward a little bit then suddenly
and simply
malinowski notified us that third first
and third battalions were caught in a
pocket
and we were moving up north to give them
a hand
and the good news is this time we ride
he signed us trucks
by squad
malinowski deployed us squads abreast
each squad to maintain this is when they
get obviously they get to their
fighting positions um each squad set to
maintain itself and calm until we closed
in for the assault then we'd move up
shoulder to shoulder side by side
to take up marching fire we topped the
ridge
and descended toward the valley that
separated us from the burning smoking
mass that was hill 554
our objective the planes banked off in a
way as we started across the valley
artillery screeched in to take up the
slack small arms fire from the hill
cracked overhead
and mal gave the order to pick it up and
get a move on chinese
artillery came alive now and the ground
beneath my feet rolled and heaved
like the deck of a ship on a raging sea
smoke
fire and steel split the air like a
tornado
and the crack of heavy artillery
pounding my ears
suddenly i was through it and on the
height of the near bank of a small
stream facing a 40-foot drop to the far
side
a machine gun opened up from the hill
ahead the rounds whizzing past my ears
and splitting the air above me
and i leaped i sailed down onto the far
bank my
boots driving through the frozen crust
into the deep cold mud
pulling myself free i bounded forward
into the next heavy cloud of smoke
the ground heaved the ground sloped
steeply upward
i had reached the base of hill 554
i shoved my bar selector to automatic
finger on the trigger
my eyes straining to pierce the smoke i
began to ascend the hill cautiously
somebody broke through to my right
my finger tightened and i damn near
dropped him it was dave
without a glance toward me he crossed in
front of me and disappeared into the
smoke
the cloud blew away for a second and i
saw him clearly both sides called off
artillery
and shouts came along the hill to keep
it moving and keep going forward
i hadn't fired a shot yet someone yelled
grenades
as they began to burst below and around
us bugs shouted
open up and the line came to life
sporadically at first
and then with a marching steam stream of
steady fire as men found their places in
the line
anything in front now was enemy or dead
i squeezed off one shot then waited
firing blind went against the grain my
father had taught me too well
i held fire but then i saw that the
tactic was sound
we were driving them back bodies tumbled
out of the smoke above
down the hill below past me i switched
the selector to automatic
rapid a wisp of smoke cleared in front
of me
and there he was burp gun the works his
face was a mask of shock
he fired first and rounds plowed into
the ground in front on both sides of me
and over my head
i dropped the butt of the bar until the
barrel aligned itself with the slope of
the hill the muzzle level with his gut
and squeezed the trigger
little puffs of smoke and dust billowed
from his uniform and drove his body
back against the hillside the weapon he
carried flew from his hands
passed me down the hill chinese voices
above were screaming in the smoke
i continued forward and picked up the
pace as i stepped past the body
i just dropped that glance down he was
dead all right
i had emptied an entire magazine into
him i wasn't as cool
as i had figured i released the empty
magazine and was inserting a new one
when one of his buddies
broke through the right front i swung
around he was a kid
he dropped his rifle then changed his
mind and made a dive for it
but he was too late i seated the
magazine with a crack on my palm
slammed the bolt forward and squeezed
the trigger his head disintegrated
i grabbed his rifle pointed up the hill
and emptied it into the smoke
then i smashed it against the hillside
and dropped the pieces
i rested my rifle in both hands and
continued up
this time i knew i had fired four rounds
there were still 16 in the magazine
i had calmed down another body broke out
of the smoke above me
my finger tightened on the trigger it
was bugs let's go we shouted we're
almost there
i caught up with him king had been hit
who else didn't know
who else he didn't know yet there were
about six of us still on the line but
the enemy was pulling out
the hill was ours shoulder to shoulder
we marched those last few yards
we were the first two to reach the top
within minutes the remainder of the
platoon moved up alongside
our squad had been cut down to four men
not a major action it was just another
hill
for which we had paid the price
but it cost the chinese dearly too
they're deadly scattered all around
we had done well we had won
then suddenly as if turned by the hand
of fate our own
artillery seemed to bounce back in
flight and began
falling onto our own positions it was
impossible
for the chinese to have spotted and
called in counter fire so quickly
but ours are theirs death was the same
in a world of lightning bolts and
thunder clapping around us
the earth underneath our boots blew up
like a volcano
mcpherson a few yards in front of me
rocketed up into the sky like a dull
like a doll in a hurricane and came down
hard and that was it
as suddenly as it began it was over i
crawled over to mack
chunks of ice and debris raining down on
us and my mouth tasted like copper
pennies
bastards he grimaced dumb stupid [ __ ]
bastards
those were our tanks
he was shaken but his only real wound
was a chunk of shrapnel
behind his right knee he was out of it
he was stateside for sure
carboni and carboni's the medic came up
and we tied a compress around the wound
with the shrapnel still inside you're
going home mack carboni said softly
i lifted him across my shoulder careful
of the knee and we made it back to the
platoon
there'd be no evacuation until their
artillery led up
and we already had eight wounded besides
mac
the platoon was down to 21 and carboni
was the biggest
busiest man in it we called back for
litter teams and blankets
but it was no easier getting things up
than it was getting them back
so we waited night came
and the incoming stuff lifted we set our
soul longs
told mac that he had made it and was
headed home for
parades and kisses
just to get home to see the family will
be enough you guys have my address
see ya to the walking wounded pick up
picked up his litter and fell behind the
others headed down the slope
we sat down and watched them wind their
way towards the trail
in the valley below six walking wounded
mac
and the other guys on litters
it was all we could spare in november
even the walking wounded would have had
to stay on and fight
so things were improving a little they
disappeared in the rocks below
and into a minefield seconds later
mack and three others came running out
of the rocks and back up the hill
men ran to help them the other five were
dead
they left the bodies and brought mack
and the others back up to the ridge
the wind picked up again and it began to
snow
everyone was too tired to waste energy
digging in
we shielded the wounded with our bodies
to keep them warm
halfway through the night a chinese unit
passed us by
by morning we were surrounded again by
afternoon the tanks had gotten through
to us
and we were able to evacuate the wounded
so mack was on his way once more
but our destinies are cut elsewhere
there was no escape at least for mac he
had survived the shrapnel
one light piece behind the knee from a
hit close enough to destroy a tank
he'd escaped the minefield we were no
longer trapped he was on his way again
and home was but a short way off
then our tanks made another one of those
errors so
common in war that most people never
hear about
one tank had not received the ward and
fired one shot
by mistake into the small band of
wounded men
it was a direct hit and mack
the other three wounded and the two we
had sent to carry the litter
were blown to bits
bitterness swept through me i sat down
in the snow and stared
numbly into the distance
the hills here still white and blue
but they look dirty the sky was a swirl
of muddy clouds
i let my head hang for a second or two
and just stared at the frozen ground
between my boots
just little ridges of frozen mud with a
light
dirty snow coating the edges
the war had lost its glamour
later at the base of the hill i raised
hell with the tank commander out of
frustration
and grief it had been a legitimate state
mistake on his part
one of the sergeants came over and
apologized i'm sorry he said it was my
fault
it's war i interrupted
it's nobody's fault i had lost my first
true friend in korea
so the the the horrible blue on blue
something that everyone in the military
everyone in the police should think
about
all the time i
promise you when things get crazy
it is way more likely
than you might think
this is an interesting part here he says
the army introduced
rotation individuals with time
could go home replaced by new men quote
starting their tours
there was a reward before the end of the
rainbow
a way out of war short of winning
it was the worst plan the army had ever
put into effect
men became cautious they did their time
and stayed alive
soldiers no longer belonged to a unit
they served in one until they completed
a tour
then served in another it was the
beginning of the end
the purpose of all living is death
i had read once
loyalty courage and comradeship
lent nobility to that purpose
in a very short time our army and
our country would come to reap the
fruits
of depriving their soldiers of that
nobility of purpose
those of us who were stuck with the old
principles
began to view ourselves as different
and counted each rotation as a loss
yeah you know in world war ii you know
when you came home from war
when we won and some guys were two three
four years
and i mean just think about what that
does to your mindset
just think about what that does oh my
god i only got four more months i only
got eight more months
one day at a time i could get through
this day
fast forward a little bit a couple of
days later i got nicked in the wrist
six of us were on patrol down along the
bank of a river
spent one night in the aid station where
they sewed me up and filled me with
drugs to prevent infection
the next morning i returned to my
platoon
mal the officer wanted me to go back to
the mash for a couple days to make sure
i was okay we compromised if
complications set in
or i began hurting i'd go back that was
that
he's just getting wounded and just
doesn't care
um this is a little later i was going to
i was going to do
get some shut eye but i never had the
chance heavy stuff
whistled in right on us in the middle of
my sentence
i a large gob of white phosphorus
landed on my left forearm and began
sizzling on its way to the bone
so we both spent the rest of the day
packing my arm with cold mud to prevent
the phosphorus from getting oxygen
while we dug out chunks with our knives
then i went to the aid station to have
the wound cleaned and sewed getting
wounded was becoming
an annoying habit the good news was that
i got another night at the old
aid station to sleep in a tent fairly
dry
on a litter which kept my ass out of the
mud
it was almost worth getting hit for a
night of uninterrupted sleep no posting
of outposts
no being awakened every 30 minutes or so
because somebody wanted me on the radio
or the sound power
no taking turns war has a way of
reducing life to the basics and bringing
home what the true comforts in life are
uninterrupted sleep is one hell of a
comfort cool water to drink is another a
dry bed
a hot cup of coffee a cigarette if
you're a smoker
i guess i'd seen enough dying men ask
for one to make me believe it was
for some a shot of whiskey
fast forward chinese troops were
reported massing about 2 000 yards north
of our permit
positions and armed recon patrols needed
to check it out
approximately fifteen hundred yards out
a sniper's bullet caught me in the
upper right arm slug went in and wrapped
around the bone it buzzed like a hammer
blow to the funny bone
but it didn't do much damage the medic
put a compress on it
we dropped down off the hill to put it
between
us and the sniper this time they sent me
all the way back to the mash
by late evening a surgeon had removed
the bullet and told me i'd be evacuated
to the rear in the morning get a good
night's sleep he said
shortly after midnight i a-walled from
the mash
and hitched a ride on a truck convey
convoy back north to the unit
i reached the platoon at noon just in
time for c rations
he's using a wall as a verb now like ia
there's got to be a better term for that
for what he's doing
like
carbony's replacement a medic named ryan
had been assigned to the platoon and
pickens a new sergeant had joined us
again i was like well you know you get
to these points you're saying i really
need to go over the
you know should i should i read this
part
and then it just teaches you teaches you
um
pickens a new sergeant had joined us no
one was certain whether he had served in
combat yet or not but he was a master
sergeant that outranked me
and i figured he must have had something
on the ball that made to make rank i
want i went to meet him
he looked like a sergeant neat trim and
in shape he wore his uniform well and
his gear was in order
he talked like a sergeant no [ __ ]
and he gave orders like a man who knew
his stuff
dave didn't like him one more gun is one
more gun i told him
not always herb he replied then changed
the subject he didn't want to talk about
it it was an odd remark
and an odd way for dave to act he was no
dope and when he said something it was
worth listening to
what he what had he observed that i had
missed i studied pickens carefully
for the next few days nothing occurred
to change my evaluation in fact
everything he did just seemed to confirm
it he had bearing
command presence intelligence training
the works
he was going to be a real asset to the
company dave was wrong
anyone could make a mistake pickens and
i supervise the digging in
and the preparation of the defense he
was great at weapons and placement
by the end of the day we had a tight
line
that could throw up a wall of steel on
command
something big was brewing on the chinese
side pickens decided we needed more
tactical wire to our front
he went to the rear himself to go pick
it up
it was dusk and the sky was calm and
beautiful and that kind of interesting
right like you feel something brewing on
the chinese side and this guy decides
he's going to go to the rear
dave is thinking hey this guy might not
be all he's cracked up to be
he seems a little seems a little too a
little too maybe a little too squared
away right
um
a little while later jennings whistled
to me hey herb
mal wants you on the sound power i went
over and took the phone from jennings
sergeant herbert
sir herb get the troops back in their
holes all hell's gonna break loose in a
minute
with my other here i could hear planes
coming in on the dive men started
running for the positions
before i even had time to shout the
planes dropped their ordinance right
overhead
i watched the canisters tumble down
through the sky out over our heads and
crashing through the trees only a few
hundred yards before us
malinowski was still talking the valley
is loaded with gooks
he was saying get the men ready full
alert
notify the op to be ready to pull in
fast when they get the word
where's pickens wilko pickens
went back for wire and hasn't returned
yet i said okay it's your baby stay in
contact roger that out
this time we had the men and ammunition
we had wire and we had land mines and
booby traps
out our fire sectors overlapped along
the entire front
this time they wouldn't be able to
afford the price
i looked up at the planes layoff guys
i muttered to myself let him come in and
give us a chance
i felt good i went along the line
briefing in each position
dude i just like underline this section
here
this is his brief to the troops nobody
moves out of position unless i give the
word know who's on your right and left
keep all gear on fix bayonets no one
throws grenades until you're certain
they're in range
remember you can hear a lot further than
you can toss a frag
make shots count don't waste ammo keep
up a good rate of fire
if word comes down to fire each man lays
his rifle against the stake and we put
it in
and fires steady at a rapid rate on that
line
all fires interlocking until i pass word
to fire at will across the entire sector
don't forget the tendency at night is to
fire too high keep aim low
we'll cream them we have fast resupply
from the rear
when ammo starts to get low don't panic
there'll be more coming
tonight belongs to easy company
good to go tonight belongs to easy
company and it did
for six waves
the first five we chopped to pieces
we would have done the same for the
sixth seventh or tenth
except that some [ __ ] back at company
rear hadn't done his job
ammunition was running low by the fifth
wave
moore was supposed to be on the way but
king called back to malinowski
and learned that the company
headquarters had withdrawn there'd be no
resupply tonight the chinese had broken
through
on the right flank where the dutch who
had been tied in with us
had already pulled out we were on our
own
then the phone went dead a round had
severed the wire or had been cut
i told king to alert the platoon to be
ready to pull out back down the hill
to the point where we had previously
designated in case we were overrun
i picked up bugs from my from the hole
to my left and we moved east along the
back of the ridge to make contact
with malinowski or to find out what had
happened to the wire
we were still moving when all hell broke
loose as the sixth wave
hit and came in over the wire and over
there dead
next thing i knew i was fighting hand to
hand for my life
the little mothers were everywhere bugs
and i killed about 12 of them before
between us before we got enough opening
to get the hell out
let's go he shouted we were bound we
and we bounded down back the side of the
hill like two fat bears toward
where our company command post had been
there was nothing but fog
either we were the last ones or the
first we dropped down behind a log and
tried to assess the situation
from here on we'd play it safe there was
no telling who was behind us
even our own troops would be edgy and
friendly fire kills the same as enemy
the rest of the platoon had either
gotten out or they were dead or captured
let's get going said bugs the chinese
had pretty well halted the ridge
halted at the ridge it was unlike their
previous attacks
when they had to be stopped by fire the
shooting petered out behind us
we moved off into the fog approximately
45 minutes later
we tied up with the loose troops from
other parts of the company who had
assembled at the pre-designated spot
i tried to find out about the platoon
the company commander had been hit and
evacuated
malinowski had been catching grenades on
the right flank and throwing them back
at the chinese when one of them had gone
off in his hand
he was in serious condition but alive
and had been evacuated
nobody knew about dave anis jennings and
the rest except
they had been ordered to pull back that
made me the platoon leader
and lieutenant canning the commanding
officer
they eventually make a move to get out
of there
and it goes relatively well except for
the fact that as they're
approaching friendly lines again they
realize that they're in a minefield
they make it through the minefield and
then they end up going back out and
they're
in another hill on another hill again
we sat waiting silently dawn lit up the
sky
and the sun started up over the hills
behind us
light crept across and down forward of
the slope
now we could see movement there were
hundreds of them
they had evidently come in right behind
us when we had been driven from our
positions the preceding night
now they were halted regrouping
i tried the sound power to notify first
battalion headquarters
but just couldn't raise anybody on the
other end i sent jennings back as a
runner
some 60 millimeter mortar light stuff
started a puff
in the air around us the chinese
suspected that someone was on the hill
they might have spotted us or the men we
had relieved
we continued to watch and held our fire
for the next two hours they dropped 60
millimeters on us
but did no damage our air came up out of
the sun
and made one orbit overhead jennings
must have gotten the message back to
battalion
the planes peeled out of order orbit
diving one after the other
the chinese below held formation
canisters of napalm tumbled down
scattering flame and twisted metal among
their ranks
still they held a bugle sounded
loud and clear from the midst of the
carnage and they came
charging up the hill now i
shouted sighting along the barrel and
squeezing the trigger of the ar
rifle fire cracked in my ears from both
sides as the rest
opened up with me our planes banked from
east to west
and the remaining canisters fell cutting
deep swaths
in the ranks of the chinese but they
kept on coming
they had manpower and they had guts we
were butchering them
but from their front line it kept
getting closer
when one went down another replaced him
our planes empty of ordinance
banked off south bugs passed word that
ammo was running low
by sight i measured the distance to the
nearest line of chinese
and squeezed the trigger in one last
burst before giving the order to move
out
the teams pulled out from right flank to
left
on order each following in falling in
behind
the one passing from its right crandall
and i went last to bring up the rear
my calculations had been accurate we
were able to pull back
down the hill across the saddle and up
into first bats positions without
drawing fire
what's more we had done a lot of damage
to the chinese as we passed through
passed through their lines the men of
first congratulated us
and asked our names i felt like one hell
of a tiger
the major congratulated and thanked us
you guys can serve in this battalion
anytime
it was a top compliment i shook his hand
saluted
and reminded him we had to get back to
her own unit
there was no transportation available as
yet he told us but tomorrow
i said we could huff it and i moved the
patrol out behind me
without waiting for an answer or looking
back
jennings met us down the road and he had
been nicked by a piece of shrapnel but
he could walk
and he didn't relish staying behind we
hitched a ride
with a deuce and a half headed southwest
had i known the outcome for us i might
not have been such a hurry to get back
canning was the only officer left alive
in the company
counting us he commanded exactly 90
enlisted men
pickens was gone this is that sergeant
we were talking about
pekens was gone according to canning he
had been avoiding combat
ever since he had arrived i was the only
one who hadn't noticed
the day after we had come off the hill
canning forced him to take out a patrol
they were creamed pickens came back
ranting about being thrown needlessly
into the jaws of death
and sank to the ground babbling canning
had a had him evacuated
combat fatigue he laughed isn't that a
pisser
anyone in the patrol dead i asked
eight any of my men
uh third platoon he ticked them off kyle
fritz moonsong donovan shoemaker
benson kandini and davis
kyle and moonsong the old ranks were cut
down by two more
you're the platoon leader of second now
until an officer gets in i acknowledged
i understood it was temporary
as long as i'm here with some say-so he
declared
we'll see i thought i was no officer
malinowski had told me he was
i was a sergeant but i had never seen
any promotion orders
i led whatever meant i was assigned
wherever i was ordered to i was still in
a wall
and it would be funny as hell if i were
still a private
there were no pay days for me my name
was never on the payroll
the records were delayed in the rear
they said i never contested it
what would i have done with money the
platoon numbered 18 men
counting me we had one machine gun
operating no rocket launchers
it amounted to no more than a heavily
reinforced rifle squad
but what the hell 90 man wasn't a
company either
yep still a wall yeah and like
replacements are coming in but they're
not getting there fast enough
now we're gonna fast forward a little
bit and
once again they're on another hill
all the chatter on the other side ceased
about at the same time
there wasn't a sound for a few minutes
then rustling and a few whispers
some rocks broke loose and tumbled down
the slope
they were crawling up the hill no bugles
this time
psychological warfare between the second
division and the chinese
was over
we had become a seasoned unit they knew
it
and we knew it they were determined to
get in close
and destroy us we were just as
determined
to let them getting close so we could
destroy them
in a very few minutes both sides would
face the moment of truth
this was burma and i was
better than harold flynn no blanks no
[ __ ]
i was not an actor but a u.s infantryman
i could beat any enemy that lived
we sat and we waited i could hear myself
breathe
as i strained my ears to measure the
distance
then bam the entire slope
beneath us was lit up beams bounced off
the clouds above
and ricocheted down the hillside
artificial moonlight
i glanced hurriedly around
and discovered buck dixon and myself to
be in the keyhole of a long finger
leading up from the valley
at the crossbar stem of a junction of
tea
i glanced down the stem and there they
were
they moved forward towards us in the
eerie light
like walking dead in a cheap horror film
i pulled the pin
from an m17 frag and sent it sailing
down the finger
the explosion drove four bodies up and
forward
into the air arms heads and legs
flailing like marionettes whose strings
had parted
the light of the explosion went out and
i didn't see how they landed
a second later we could make out about
10 more towing a machine gun on wheels
buck let fly this time taking out both
gun and crew
so far the score was a u.s about 14 or
maybe 20 counting the advance element
chinese nothing a shutout
which didn't hold for long but the next
group that broke out of the woods to our
front wasn't any lead element
or single machine gun crew it was a
whole
damn army all along our front
our men opened up all along the line
bodies tumbled along the entire slope
before us
a whistle blew once and just as suddenly
as we had poured it on to them they
returned it to us
a wall of solid steel drove into our own
positions now
two grenades landed in our hole and
bucks scooped them up
and flung them back down the hill three
more landed and he did the same
this hole's too damn big dixon shouted
and they got us spotted
another grenade came sailing through the
air towards us bail out i yelled
and all three of us cleared the position
as one two seconds later the grenade
went off inside with a loud
whoop buck and dixon had gone right me
left
i rolled over on my stomach smack up
against self propelled
he had a shelter half stretched out on
the ground it was field stripping a
machine gun
on it methodically and unheardly as if
you were giving a demonstration
he hardly glanced at me keep him off me
herb until i get this mother working
three chinese raced up and emptied their
weapons into the hole
we had just left buck was reloading his
carbine
get him herb he yelled but dixon fired
first
blowing the head off the guy on the
right i dropped the other two
then ran my bayonet into one as he
tumbled by me
a grenade exploded among us and i felt
myself flung backward down the hill
chinese broke over the top of the ridge
a bayonet slashed my upper right arm
down the hill men screamed all along the
line buck grabbed me and yanked me to my
feet let's go man he shouted another
grenade went off behind us
propelling the three of us ass over
heels down the rear slope
buck jumped back to his feet first a
body broke out of the smoke above us
self-propelled i shouted son of a [ __ ]
the figure shouted back a grenade in his
hand buck tore his head off with a burst
of about 20.
[ __ ] he said hardly raising his
voice above a worster
whisper visit your ancestors
we fought our way down the valley as far
as we could tell we were alone
but the chinese were all around us in
the melee we got separated
bruce and dixon went one way me another
i rounded a bush and stumbled into ryan
and king
let's go i said and started back down
the valley toward the town
we're heading the wrong way ryan argued
uh-uh i fired back this is it
the artificial moonlight went out
suddenly leaving us in darkness with
much of our
night sight shot i held us up for a bit
to let our eyes accommodate a bullet
passed through my left leg just above
the ankle
i could walk but my arm was getting a
little stiff i noticed king was limping
you hit i whispered about three times no
broken bones though
you ryan nothing he whispered holt
a voice snapped sharply in front of us
gi's
i whispered back okay come on in there
were seven of them
that made ten so
just to debrief what just happened
freaking insane mayhem is what just
happened
these guys are getting attacked by the
chinese they get pretty much
overrun they all bail out of the
positions they kind of fall back
in the direction of the last known area
that they
think they could go to is which is this
town on the way they're
getting separated and re-linking up with
other guys
and then finally they link up with seven
other guys so now we have 10 of them
one of them suggested we take off down
the riverbed ryan wanted a hole up in
the brush until daylight
i nixed both suggestions we'd go into
town as a patrol
there had to be other elements of the
regiment there
the decision made i moved up front to
take over
we had one more contact with the chinese
machine gunner whom we bypassed in the
dark either because he was dead
at the gun asleep or confused three
members of the patrol dropped off on
their own and headed down the riverbed
ryan disappeared and showed up three
years later
as a returned pow the remaining six so
they're just losing guys guys are just
dropping off
the remaining six of us made it into the
town out of the frying pan into the fire
we had just broken through to a
battalion headquarters which was
surrounded
a major was in charge i recognized him
as a regular heller
he talked tough looked tough and was
tough
how many of you are there he asked
crisply six
it's a help not a division but a help a
radio
crackling nearby informed us that there
was no way to break through
to us until daylight they wanted us to
hold the major return
we don't have enough ammo left in last
to last an hour
a flare burst above us caught
caught us standing there in the open
here we go again the major shouted and
rushed past
us toward the patty on our east for lack
of any place better to go we followed
dropping down into firing positions just
in time to catch about three or
four hundred enemy crossing the patty
toward us at a trot guns spewing
three or four hundred
we were next to a machine gun and
between us we laid down a field of fire
that cut them down like a scythe mowing
wheat
not a single one of them reached the
perimeter how long has this been going
on i asked one of the gunners
all night we let them pull back they're
dead and wounded
in the lull we introduced ourselves to
each other their names were lorac and
macleod
neither one seemed any more distressed
or nervous about the situation than i
was
they went about their business coolly
and professionally making adjustments in
the headspace of their weapon
getting more boxes of ammo ready and
jokingly with each other and with us
remember the message out of baton in
world war ii when the
when we were being overrun lorac josh
send more japs
a young lieutenant came up behind us and
introduced himself hurriedly
name's benkowski he made a quick pitch
we can break out and some of us will
make it he looked me in the eye
are you for it i nodded the rest of you
guys they nodded too
so there's a plan we can try and get out
of here and some of us
might be able to make it
okay benkowski said we're gonna muster
at the south edge of the village on
order
when they make the next assault we'll
meet them head on got it
got it macleod echoed the rest of us
nodded he turned and raced away i sat
down to think i'd always heard that when
your
time came to die your life flashed
before your eyes
i tried to summon it but got nowhere my
mother
father all those things were too far
away i thought of some things i should
have done differently but not too many
i should have kicked some asses i didn't
and i should have said some words to
some people that i didn't
if i made it out i'd never make those
mistakes again
if i made it out if not then i'd take as
many of them with me as i could
my thoughts were interrupted by the word
coming down to assemble at the south end
of the village
no sooner would we there when a flare
broke overhead lighting up the entire
column
a machine gun opened up from the road
directly in front of us son of a [ __ ]
that benkowski mumbled
we gotta get that gun gotta get that gun
the words echoed through my brain
two maybe three lousy guys weighing less
than 150 pounds each
holding up the entire us army [ __ ]
life was okay but not that okay i
scrambled to my feet and raced forward
another guy came up with me step for
step
and we headed south down the road
together covering
for the first 30 yards side by side
then there was this sickening thud of
high speed metal whacking into flesh
as i as my companion went down beside me
at just the moment i spotted the gun
position
i was 20 yards off 20 yards out and
slightly off to the right
and i managed to get within five yards
the gun before they spotted me
and into the hole with them before they
could squeeze off around
they were kids my bayonet ripped through
the chest of the gunner
driving them up against the back wall of
the position pulling it loose i beat the
second man to death with my rifle butt
bayoneted the third then took a bayonet
in the side myself
from the fourth as i drove the butt down
into his skull
which jerked the rifle from his hands
and snapped the bayonet off inside my
chest
bastard i hissed as i pounded his skull
one more time for good measure
my buddies were streaming past me i
leaped out of the hole
and joined the rush a second later two
chinese flyweights pounced on my back
i reached back to grab some hair and
picked up a fistful of teeth
i stumbled and fell and the three of us
went down held her skelter
i bounded back up alone and was off
again flares burst off above us
lightning lighting the sky with flame
grenades were exploding all around
men were screaming on both sides then we
were in the midst of the chinese running
parallel to the river
the major tripped in front of me and
went down i reached down to pull him up
go on get out save yourself he shouted
at me thrusting his pistol up into my
hand
here take it he was a small man i yanked
him to his feet and threw him across my
shoulder
we crossed the river and we were out of
it
some men lifted the major from my
shoulders
there were 11 of us benkowski's arm hung
limpy at his side
only one of us a sergeant from the first
ranger company had come through without
a scratch
another mile down the road we met the
unit on its way up to break through to
us
there were men from easy company with it
my legs were a little rubbery
young malchik another pennsylvanian
raced with me
back to the aid station the doc took one
look at me
and said the war is over for you soldier
you're on your way to the states
young said goodbye see you back home i
waved my hand at him
seeing a couple days man the major asked
me to write my name down
he was going to put me in for the medal
of honor i picked up the scrap
of paper from one of the field clerks
and wrote herbert on it and handed it to
one of the medics
i laid down on a litter and fell asleep
crazy
i think what's that he's been wounded
with a bayonet three times
including one that gets broken off in
his chest
an ambulance left me at the 11th evac
hospital unit
where they took the out the bayonet took
out the shrapnel took out the slug then
tagged me for japan and further
evacuation to stateside
but i didn't mean to go home yet i
begged the docks to let me recuperate
where i was
i swore i felt fine but they said it was
impossible
i needed rest besides there were rules
there had been
internal bleeding and i had lost a lot
of blood one of them suggested that i
volunteer to come back in a few months
in short the answer was no i could stay
at the 11th long enough to see
jennifer jones who has arrived the next
day the day after i would be evacuated
first to japan
then to the states jennifer came in the
morning
and shook hands with each of us the
doctor told her my story as if i were a
hero
and she invited me for steak when i got
back home she was beautiful
she was real and down to earth she was
going to have dinner with the wounded
men that night
but i missed dinner when she came back
i slipped out a different exit i talked
the sergeant at supply into letting me
have some fatigues and a rifle
then i hitched a ride north and returned
to my unit
wounds still draining i told them at
battalion
that the docks had said to have the
medic change the dressings periodically
and give me shots when i needed them the
wounds were to be bound and stitched
after they had drained
no one questioned it and i was given a
lift down to easy company
technically is that a wall no right yeah
yeah yeah well it is actually a wall
because you're you're being ordered to
do something and then you're not doing
it right
being ordered to go to japan and you're
not going there
the company was on a sort of low-level
reserve not anything we hadn't been
not anything like what we had been on
back in the spring but rather regimental
reserve we were in defensive positions
short of the front ready to reinforce
whatever regiment
needed or to be ready on call
to spearhead the company had a new co
canning was the executive officer again
three new lieutenants had come into the
first
third and weapons platoon command of
second platoon was still mine
canning had been true to his word i'd
only been gone for a few days but barely
recognized the unit everyone treated me
like something special i was told i've
been submitted for an entire
[ __ ] pot full of awards
but dave wasn't about to get me to bite
on any of that [ __ ] me and who else
i said
i met captain west the new co
and the new three new lieutenants tim's
an ex-marine
lieutenant dubois from dubois street
in dubois in dubai pennsylvania
and lieutenant from the sovereign state
of texas who wanted to know why if i was
such a damn good platoon leader i wasn't
an officer
i have pull i explained captain west was
a
down-home type he was tall and lanky and
served as a commander in world war ii
he had been recalled out of korea for
the reserves he made it clear that he
would fight but he wouldn't take jackass
chances
he talked real clear and plain
we also received our first black
replacements
there were rumors that battalion
headquarters had balked at it
and that there had been a knock down
drag out brawl at regiment
that ended when our co was told there
would be no more rotation until we
accepted black replacements
so the regimental co had softened we'd
try a couple
if things didn't work out after a month
it would be discussed again
easy company got one he was a super
soldier
probably one of the finest sergeants in
the whole damn army
the men were more than satisfied with
him from the day he arrived
it was the officer corps and the ass
kissing senior
ncos at regimental and battalion
headquarters who oppose the idea of
integration
most of the troops didn't care one way
or the other
the entire tenor of the war had changed
and this is fast forward a little bit
things were much better we had broken
the chinese spring offensive the second
division was credited as having
destroyed more than 92 000 chinese
regulars
more than 36 000 of whom were dead in
that one three-day action
word was that the north was ready to
commence peace talks
bugs was m.i.a he was last seen
standing on a paddy dyke out of ammo
swinging an entrenching tool as he went
down under a pile of chinese
jennings was missing in action most of
the replacements we had gained and gone
down
and gained and trained had gone down
fighting
some no doubt were mia and might show up
as pows later
there were men to be trained this part
of the country was new to me so i had
maps to study our unit was not going to
sit on its ass for long
we're going to push north
this is where you start to see
you know um a different part of his
character maybe not a different part but
you start to see
a some of some of his character come
through again that defines some of his
future i mean one of it was him
looking at the the black replacements
going like yeah
no factor let's do this and the other
one is
well another good indicator of his
let's say his character and his mindset
was uh they haven't started having some
issues with some gorillas
and so the gorillas stepped in again and
we started to take sniper fire daily
the union was ordered to burn out some
villages to deny them
a base of operations west assigned me
the mission
and i refused i tried to explain that i
hadn't joined the army or volunteered
for korea to fight civilians or burn
their hooches
the discussion was getting sticky when
carlson volunteered
and got both myself and west off the
hook it was a fatal error for carlson
he took one through the chest from a
sniper and went home in a body bag
i had hardly known the man yet i felt
the same terrible emptiness when he died
as i had when mack had bought the farm
west asked me if i'd like to go out and
burn the villages now
no i said and he didn't push it
what exactly is a gorilla a gorilla is
a non-uniformed fighter so
if it's a it's someone that's dressing
up like a civilian
and they're maybe acting like the
civilian but they're not in an organized
military so they don't have a uniform
they have a chain of command but it's
it's underground
so for instance in vietnam there were
the vietnamese regulars the nva
they were army soldiers with uniforms
but then there was also
the vc right you've heard that
expression that's the vietcong
so they might live in a village and act
like a farmer
but then at night they have ak-47 hidden
and they attack that's a guerilla
fighter so
are they independent or are they like
working
you know a little bit of both they're
gonna be they're
gonna be less organized than a
traditional
military unit would be a conventional
military unit
so they're going to be a little less
organized than that just
due to the fact that you know they're
they're spending some of their time
as civilians but they don't
but do they answer to like let's say you
know in vietnam like
do the yeah so the viet cong has a chain
of command and a structure and things
like that and there's senior
viet cong and there's senior guerrillas
in this situation
but they're not they're not fully
uniformed
and i'm sure i'm like could there's
probably a more technical
definition than what i'm giving yeah but
that's the general principle
is a guerrilla fighter is not
in an organized uniformed situation
and probably is more or less a part-time
soldier even though like viet cong there
was professional viet cong meaning
they didn't have some other job but and
this is
you could say the insurgents in iraq
same thing
yeah and and you could say that once the
insurgents became isis and started
wearing like black uniforms and flying a
big flag that was
it's almost like they're not gorillas
anymore yeah they're an organized
military
unit yeah that was kind of their uniform
they're in the black
interesting all right so
um once again they're on another hill
i had left you know it's so crazy to
think like
that story of him attacking that machine
gun nest where he saves the major and
all that
that kind of
that that kind of could be the end of
the book right i mean he's stabbed
yeah he's got a bayonet in his chest
he's been shot
you can kind of say like okay that's
probably a good place
to go home for him and maybe end the
book and all that
it's not it's just not even close
so they're on another hill i had left a
listening post three men
above and forward of the original
positions when the chinese moved in they
came
around midnight at about company size
the yelp the listing post picked them up
and phoned the word about 100 of them
right on positions
get down in your hole sit tight i
answered then i called back to company
and radio 2 concentration numbers roy
alerted the
patrol to be ready to open fire on the
old positions on command which would be
immediately after the first round of
artillery exploded
figuring we must have pulled back the
chinese began to chatter carelessly
suddenly there was one loud whoosh
followed by three more and the world
blew up in their faces
fire exploded the entire finger and draw
lighting up the night in red
yellow and orange flashes silhouettes of
bodies shown against the blaze
winging through the sky smashing up
against trees and rocks i gave the
signal
and the platoon opened up when it was
over we had destroyed the entire company
or rather the artillery head there was
no question about it artillery
destroyed more enemy in combat than all
other services combined including the
air force
death was sudden ripping ripping violent
most of the time however we used it
badly and it was a waste
tonight we had worked well together and
the chinese had paid the price
i radioed back the results west wanted
me to take the platoon
out across and verify i told him i would
at first light
he told me he wanted to do it now so he
could notify battalion
i told him i would do it at first light
and signed off
he called back two more times trying to
raise me i whispered for sykes to turn
down the volume
quiet settled over the area once again
at first light
so there's a little little leadership
you know little leadership scenario
getting told to do something that
probably doesn't make a lot of sense
right now hey just kind of turn down
that radio a little bit
don't answer at first light i moved the
patrol back across the draw and we
verified our three men were unscratched
the entire chinese company including
parts of their officers were present
accounted for
and dead i radioed the results to west
good good he said great and then with a
pause
come on in we'll send a replacement
platoon down
not necessary we don't have any
casualties i'll just send a party back
for more ammo
then as an afterthought we'll have to
move though
it's going to smell pretty bad down here
after the sun comes up
sure certainly he said whatever you feel
is okay
just give us your coordinates and we'll
when you get settled in
wilco sir out and i just
highlighted that part because you can
see even though west was pushing him to
kind of go out there and check but at
the end of the day
he trusts what he trusts what his guy on
the front line says
we don't need to pull out may need some
more ammo have to adjust our position
and it's just a good thing to see
fast forward a little bit i was called
down to regimental headquarters and
offered a battlefield commission to
second lieutenant
next time we were in reserve i was to
receive what dave
had called that [ __ ] pot full of
decorations the colonel commanding the
regiment explained that
many advantages i would have as an
officer and a gentleman
but it was crazy i didn't even have an
education i told him i preferred being
enlisted man for the time being
then he said you deserve to be the
highest ranked one over here
and he promoted me to master sergeant on
the spot he broke out a bottle and
offered me a drink at the time i neither
smoked nor drink but i thanked him and
sipped it
while he discussed the possibility of my
coming back for a commission when i
changed my mind
i thanked him for the promotion and the
drink again and then went back to the
platoon
so he almost got the battlefield
commission and said no likes being an
e-dog
west picked up a piece of shrapnel
actually the next day fox company passed
through their lines into the valley they
swung east on the road and meandered
through the wide
low flat farmland to a major terrain
feature behind
beyond hill 6 868 on the map
they fought and died for that peak for
the next two days and nights with us
just sitting there listening to the
battle rage
west picked up a piece of shrapnel from
an incoming 81
mortar round and we received a
replacement for him
a tiny wiry red-headed
irish man with a waxed handlebar
mustache
that was the pride of korea any man who
can best me at
indian wrestling is a better man than i
and can run the company
he announced none of us knew what the
hell indian wrestling was
so he ran the company and he ran it well
i i like put nine stars next to this
here's a good leader
he joked with the men he carried more
than his share of the load
he took his turn at watch in the command
post bunker
he carried an m1 rifle like the rest of
us he cooked his own rations
and shared his water and coffee
he was the best we'd had canning
accepted
there was no difficulty in getting the
men to follow him or do their damnedest
for him and he sure did
his damnedest frost so there you go man
there you go
hmm so this one point look i was
there's a there's a part that i'm gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna
summarize a little bit of it so
basically what happens is there's these
four chinese deserters
that that end up with the company
the cat basically they capture them
they're not they don't capture them but
they're deserters and they come over and
say we surrender basically
and then they say that there's going to
be a 30-man
combat patrol that so a a north korean
patrol is going to
go down this particular riverbed due
north of the positions that they're in
and canning the officer didn't believe
him sounds like a setup right
oh you're trying to get us to go down
there and set up an ambush so he doesn't
really believe him
and
herbert does believe the guys and he
kind of talks about how he
psychologically was trying to figure out
why would these guys do this they're
really surrendering
like why would four of them surrender
why would you just send one to surrender
why are you sending
four guys to surrender so he kind of
goes through his
psychological profile of guys and he
believes them
so i tried to talk canning and the new
co into letting me
set up an ambush for them but canning
had prevailed and the
the best the new ceo would do is let me
drop one machine gun team down to the
valley on the river
um turns out that
the chinese guys had told the truth the
gun crew and so now he did get one gun
crew down there
the gun crew opened up a couple minutes
short of midnight they had caught the
patrol in the riverbed
but the patrol was larger than
anticipated and now
they the machine gun crew was under
attack the new ceo
called me on the sound power no i
couldn't pull my platoon offline and go
back to reinforce the gun crew but i
would
take or send six men to do the best they
could i rapidly ticked off the names of
my six best men
as uh to the squad leaders i told them
to have
them on the trail behind the positions
and i picked them up one by one and
moved toward the junction that led down
to the valley below us
we tried to hurry and busted our asses
slipping and falling
over each other in the mud we hit the
flats and started across the battalion
heavy mortar section
was in position i asked the co to have
canning notify them
we were on the way and to be on the
lookout for us so i'm going to say that
again
we asked the co to have canning notify
them
that we were on the way and to be on the
lookout for us
one or the other had failed and their
guards opened up with small arms fire
without bothering to challenge us
dumas went down dead
we dropped into a small gully and
maneuvered toward the riverbed our gun
crew is still pouring the lead
we broke out of the gully 75 yards east
of them caught between their fire and
the chinese patrol i yelled for the gun
crew to hold fire and they did
now it was us in the patrol in the
riverbed i cautioned my men to play it
cool
to use bayonets where they could no
automatic fire under any circumstances
all automatic fire would be considered
enemy we spread out and moved ahead
slowly
the chinese were in a panic they broke
out of the niches and crevices and one
of the in ones and twos
and we dropped them with singer file or
laced a bayonet through their guts
first light broke and we had the
sergeant and the platoon leader trapped
they came out with their hands up we
marched them onto the valley road
and had them hunkered down with their
hands clasped across the tops of their
head
i left a man to guard them and went back
to take the tally
we had wiped out the patrol except for
our two prisoners
the deserters had told the truth there
had been 30 of them
heavily armed but now 28 of them were
dead
there were sporadic shots up ahead but
nothing to get excited about
i returned to the road then moved up to
where i had posted my guard over the two
pows
they were all dead the men from the
mortar cruise had opened up on them with
small arms
i saw bloody red i swung in the
direction of the mortars and aimed my
rifle from the hip
one of their sergeants popped up i'm
sorry herbert we didn't know
he dropped his carbine and raised his
hands we didn't know
he apologized no one told us
i lowered my rifle my fault
i said not yours
so if you didn't quite catch that he
that the mortar company did not know
that there was friendlies around there
and he had actually they had captured
these prisoners and he left the guard
with them and the mortar team killed
them all
both the captured enemy people and the
and the
guards
so and there you go i mean that's a
that's uh extreme ownership right my
fault not yours
blue on blue
fast forward a little bit we had
received two replacements one was named
a lieutenant named manning the other a
sergeant was killed by a single
artillery round which dropped into our
positions that morning
no one in the unit except the ceo had
even heard his name
life was that dumb war was stupid if
there was a god then he was stupid
there was neither rhyme nor reason to
that man's death and he meant no more
than us than a chunk of clay when we
passed him on the way out
now i i mentioned like for a split
second that fox company was headed up to
this hill
868 and now these guys they didn't get
there
fox company didn't get it done they took
massive casualties
and now easy companies heading up there
and they get pinned down in this one
particular spot
and well here they are manning caught up
with me
what's happening he asked excitedly i
was in a crater my back against the wall
there was no sense in doing anything
until the mortars let up
there was no sense in getting excited
either i don't know lieutenant why don't
you pop your head up and take a look and
then tell me
i joked and he did it
the machine gun ripped off a volley and
he dropped back into my lap two rounds
through the mouth
in one cheek through the tongue smashing
some teak
some teeth and out on the other cheek he
was okay considering what it could have
been
my s the co was next he moved into the
position with his radio
with his radio man what do you have up
there herbie asked
mainly the machine gun sir we'll get it
after it gets dark
that's not good enough he said the
regimental co is watching through the
glasses he wants it now
kami and to turn to look at us then let
that [ __ ] come up and take it he said
come on sir i interrupted fox company's
been up here for weeks without moving
all we need is a few more hours the 23rd
is moving
is moving up the old man said we've got
to have that hill today
i rolled over on my gut and gave kami in
the signal to get ready
in the next four hours 61 of us rounded
that junction
11 of us made it two-thirds of the way
to the top
along the final bar
the machine gunner at the top of the
hill got the rest
so knight found 11 of us almost at the
top
and the rest of us either cut to ribbons
or unable to move
at 3 in the morning the chinese launched
a counter attack down the ridge to drive
us back
weeding us down to eight we still had
radio contact with the ceo and he wanted
to know if we could hold out
we're not backing up i replied hang in
there herb
i've got a 57 coming up hang in there
he was referring to a 57 caliber of 57
millimeter
recoilless rifle it could take out the
machine gun all right
but it would have to be a direct hit
every half hour or so for the remainder
of the night he called the check on how
we were making out
just before daylight he joined us with
the 57
and before we could stop him he was
through us and made a one-man attack on
the position
and he almost had it we gave him as much
covering fire as we could but just short
of the position he went down
pulling the trigger of the 57. the round
plowed into the sandbags right of the
opening
two feet off total victory and blew the
old man back down the hill ass over tea
kettle which saved his life
a call came in from the regiment a
platoon of fox company would push
through us and take the final bunker
private irvin stern
from north dakota took two rounds
through the chest
he never even asked to be evacuated he
apologized for
being a problem i could have hugged him
the platoon from fox company moved up to
us the lieutenant in charge wanted to
talk until it was time for the assault
so i listened
he had a wife and kids
he never expected to make it
pickens and dubois flashed through my
mind he didn't intend to make it but if
he didn't
someone else would have to that someone
was me
with kamian and the six we had left and
against a machine gunner with the
determination and guts that that bastard
had
we weren't going to make it so when the
lieutenant moved his men out toward the
peak
i had my last troop stand
stand ready to reinforce if necessary
as he stepped out to follow his platoon
i cracked him with the butt of jordan's
carbine
and raced out through his troops the
gunner above
opened fire and raked the hill
splattering dust and mud all around
around us men began to fall back i
grabbed them and pushed them back up the
hill get that [ __ ] i shouted get
him
one of fox company's men shouted okay
big deal let's get him
and then raced me kamian was leading our
own six up the ridge
men started tossing grenades from both
sides and in the confusion
one blew the gun away and we had the
hill
we had lost buck who had been sent to
the rear wounded
and was captured down by the brook by a
chinese patrol
nelson was dead the ceo our top-notch
black test case
manning everyone in my platoon was
either dead
or wounded except kamian and myself
word came up that we would be relieved
kamian said it was about
time then he rolled over the body of one
of our troops who had bought the farm
the night before
and a grenade exploded this war was
getting to be a real pain in the ass
we sat there him wounded now
and only me in one piece waiting for our
relief
when the relief showed up roy could
still walk we moved back down the
ridgeline together
one of the relief asked him who we were
and he replied
easy company 38th infantry
at the west end of the valley we caught
up with those few troops
from our company that hadn't been
committed and that had been moved back
by the battalion co
maggie higgins was interviewing them the
battalion co
introduced me to her she asked me to
wait a moment
while she conduct while she concluded
talking with someone else
she turned her head and i walked off i
wasn't about to wait for anyone ever
again
maggie's loss i said to myself turning
back toward the kansas line i joined the
remnants of what had been easy company
moving back up the hill out of the
valley and away from hill
868.
and again you think okay well this got
to be kind of the
the end right this has to be kind of the
end of this
what he's going through
but it's not and he kind of reflects on
it a little bit he says i was getting to
know
men types were predictable
and the world is becoming less
complicated there were men and there
were fakes
a man either was or he wasn't and the
rest was all play acting
i was 21 and i was already an old man
i had to shake it or i'd become a bona
fide pain in the ass so i started to
listen
more than i talked and was somewhat
reserved with the men
war felt different there was no
apprehension no excitement everything
seemed routine and easy
i was going to make it unless a stray
round held but had my name on it
and that was damned unlikely i had
become a survivor
some men lived and some men died i would
live
there was more than just war for me but
for now i was still in
korea we were on the line
and across the valley lay the next major
objective i was ordered to report to
battalion headquarters for briefing
so you get done with an operation where
every
you lose everybody is either dead or
wounded
and you achieve your objective and you
get back into the next objective
um he does a little stint
and i'm gonna skip past this part but he
does a little stint with
as a marine corps liaison and does an
assault with the marines and loses nine
of the marines that he's with and then
after that he goes back to easy company
again
we returned to the same positions we'd
been pulled off of this is back with
easy company and rain began to fall
i had been in korea one year most men
were rotating stateside within nine
months but i was still awol
with no records i might be here forever
it was okay with me i knew the country i
knew the war
and i was well on my way to knowing
myself
one day the war would end or else i'd go
stateside with a million dollar
shot either way i'd be thankful i'd
never again waste a moment of life
and no one ever again would be able to
take even a second of it from me
i felt terrific screw rotation life was
my oyster
korea was my pearl
going back out on another patrol
we crossed the road and started up a
hill complex beyond the fog lifting
beneath behind and beneath us the world
was still calm
we picked our way carefully silently i
stopped once and glanced back
i felt damn good i felt proud i felt
american god damn it we were the best
just off the peak they had a major gun
position
a russian heavy machine gun two crew
members were standing outside
shooting the breeze having a smoke i
gave a signal for the patrol to fan out
on both sides of the trail
i wanted those two taken silently and
alive
i motioned for the two scouts to cover
me then just as i was about to start
forward to take them someone triggered a
booby trap
both crew members made a break for their
bunker and i had to drop them
so much for surprise we still had shock
action
and we were at the top in their
positions
with their key guns and most of their
ammo in effect we had the hill
we could hold it as long we could hold
it long enough for george company to
reinforce
then nobody was going to take it back so
i had to skip some stuff
because it's a pretty detailed
explanation of what's going on but
basically they were kind of heading up
this this
into this position and they almost get
fully in the position they get close
enough to where
they're going to be able to actually
capture the people that are in that gun
without any without giving themselves
away but somebody you can hear somebody
hits a booby trap
but once the booby trap goes they just
kind of continue with the assault they
don't get they kill the guys instead of
capturing them but they get there
and they capture this freaking hill and
this hill didn't really go too much into
it but it's a very prominent terrain
feature
and so it's like surprising that they
get there
uh and and and he says at the end there
we could hold the hill long enough for
george company to reinforce
and once george company was there they
would have the hill known to be able to
take it from him
but george company never showed by late
afternoon
there were six of us still alive and we
could hardly see over the dead around us
every time i called battalion i got word
that george company was almost to us
hang on
randolph was reloading magazines into
the bar
they're not coming sarge we're almost
out of ammo
get the old man on the horn i'd give it
one more try
he wasn't available according to the
radio man i glanced back down the trail
we'd come up so
skillfully so easily so damn sure of
ourselves the chinese must find it
unbelievable that we hadn't reinforced
yet
they didn't know we were down to six
almost out of ammo
if we made a break now and ran like hell
we might be able to make it before they
would close in on
us i sent one final message tell the old
man we're pulling out
then without waiting for a roger or any
other [ __ ] like i'd been getting all
day
i gave the word to saddle up they stared
at me in disbelief
what about george company there isn't
any george company now god damn it pack
up and get ready to move
add a dud run down the trail nobody
stops until he crosses the road
then hold up and provide cover for the
rest of us ready
i destroyed the maxim and picked up our
own lmg
i began to take off names keith go nick
go daniels go thompson go
i re i turned to randolph go and we were
halfway down the hill before they caught
on
that it wasn't a diversion or another
tactic but that we were bugging out
i took a round through the fleshy part
of my calf randolph took one through the
chest
and a second through the head he was
dead before he hit the ground
everyone else made it across the road
without a scratch then held up and
covered for me while i got randolph's
body out
i was puffing like a winded horse
i'm sorry
four of them i'm just [ __ ] sorry
they would have to be crazy to ever
trust me again thompson patted me on the
shoulder
you ain't george company sarge
but it wasn't george company either they
had never been alerted for standby
no one had believed we could ever make
it to the top
and then when we did they didn't think
we could ever hold out all day
the new s2 at the battalion tried to
explain to me that george company
would get the hill back tomorrow
if a patrol of 24 could do it it would
be a cinch for a full company
and he was green so he really believed
it it wasn't even worth explaining
i had been dealing with [ __ ] like
him on
on and off for almost a year now i went
over to the aid station and had them
tend to my wound
the regimental co had me back to the
rear again
the same night and apologized
no one had notified him that we'd made
it to the top he was sorry about my
troops
but i brought back valuable intelligence
now the hill would be easy
i tried to explain what was really on
that hill that neither george company
nor the entire battalion was going to
take it now
we had blown our chance you're just hurt
herbert you'll see
and we saw george company was chopped to
pieces
the battalion failed the 38th
regiment failed they had to bring in the
ninth regiment
part of the 23rd regiment the french
battalion
and part of the 14th regiment the battle
raged for four weeks
we lost nearly 5 600 men
1900 dead 3 700 seriously wounded
before it was secured
heartbreak ridge
we could have had it for free
and it would have gone unnamed and
unremembered except for one commander
who had not believed in his troops
a couple of days later halfway up
another hill i was ordered to turn my
platoon over to my assistant and report
back to company headquarters
where i was provided with a jeep to
regiment bypassing italian
another jeep to division and onto seoul
eighth army headquarters
so you i'm sure you've heard of
hamburger hill i mean just like a
crazy battle and you got the casualties
right there
1 900 dead 3700 seriously wounded
and they had taken the hill before it
had been reinforced
so you can see he gets this this is a
provided with these jeeps back to
battalion back to regiment back to
division
and then all the way back to seoul where
the eighth
army headquarters is
and this is what happens we wheeled into
soul
and into the compound everyone was in
class a's except myself and the jeep
driver
i'd never been this far to the rear in
my life not even in the states
the mp at the gates gates checked our
identification then stood back and
saluted
what the hell gave him the idea of us
were officers i couldn't figure but to
save time i returned it
your quarters are at number eight
sergeant herbert over there he pointed
at a building across the compound
well at least he knew i was a sergeant i
hadn't asked the driver for his rank
thanks corporal i replied
then turned to the driver you staying i
asked uh sarge
ah sarge got to get back saved you time
then
i jumped out of the jeep and lit next to
the corporal
take your bag sarge don't have any son i
was 21
i turned back to the jeep driver thanks
it's an honor sarge
he saluted me offhandedly spun the jeep
around in a cloud of dust and brought
back through the gate
he disappeared up the road in a second
later in the afternoon after a good bath
and washing some of the filth out of my
fatigues
i sought out the nco club it wasn't open
yet so i went back to my room took
another back
bath and fell asleep
i had a terrible dream it was one which
would
reoccur for years i was charging a
machine gun nest
not a bunker but one in a hole
like the one at con mon gao
then with bayonet fixed out of ammo
right on the edge
the earth gave way beneath my feet and i
was going backwards
my guts unguarded my rifle flung up in
an attempt to really regain my
balance but i was going over backwards
and i woke up in a sweat
i got a hold of myself in a second saw
where i was
and laid down and went back to sleep to
be awakened next
by light footsteps at my door it was a
young lieutenant
everything satisfactory sergeant he
asked cheerfully
great sir but why all the service what
the hell is it all about
it was just what he needed to trigger
him off the un command had decided to
send two
outstanding soldiers from the command on
a goodwill tour of europe state saw
stateside god knows where else our best
he said
another soldier of the month contest i
thought i remember the mp at the gate
in the class a's and glanced at myself
in the mirror
i was ragged assed and tired i didn't
have a chance
and i didn't much give a damn i was
beyond that i rushed the lieutenant out
took another bath dressed slung my bar
and closed the door behind me all i had
to do was hitch another ride north
and i'd be back to easy company within
two days
the corporal was still at the gate where
you headed
sarge he asked home man
home back to my outfit
but sarge hey man do i look like soldier
of the month material i asked
he shook his head in the nicest way any
human being
ever had before or since
uh-uh sarge you look like the toughest
mother that's over here
and our most decorated soldier
he had tears in his eyes you're going
out man
they're picking a guy to go with you he
lifted the rifle from my shoulder
and you ain't gonna need this anymore
so
well that is a
good place to stop for this particular
book
for this pretty much where you know
there's an epilogue
that you should read but the story
ends there for this book but it's the
end of the book but it's not the end of
the story
and i won't even
crack open this next book yet
which is gonna pick up with what happens
throughout his life and his career in
the army
after korea after some
mayhem in vietnam where we're gonna
learn a lot about leadership a lot about
life a lot about human nature
and um we're gonna learn some lessons
so we will save that
for next time to um
prevent having a seven hour podcast at
this time
until then echo speaking of life
sure crazy story right crazy i mean
insane
yeah yeah
like un unreal right right
like it's not real like it's so crazy
and unbelievable yeah it's like time and
time and time and time again
yeah you're like how many well uh nine
lives for a cat
yeah what's he on i think he's on 17.
it's crazy how he has like that much i
don't even know what you'd call it where
he's just
down for the caught for the fight just
to be
like i guess though right like when
you're when you grow up just
hardcore mining town no
like just just
hard you see your brothers go off to war
you see them coming home telling stories
about what's going on
just embedded is there right there's
like embedded
um desire to be in war
for many young men
right and i can't say everybody i want
to make that statement i can't talk
about
females because i don't i didn't
interact with females as much but like
when you're in a seal platoon you're
with a lot of guys
that what they wanted to do growing up
was go to war
myself included like
that's what that's what you grow up with
so there's got to be some kind of
instinctual thing yeah
yeah like i mean maybe oversimplifying
it would be like
that's his 100 purpose in life yeah
so yeah whatever i get ban added
a million times shot blown up shot
again failure this guy lets you down
this group lets you down higher ups
letting you down
shot up again and okay like let me
let me literally break the law
many times by the way to get back to war
you know what else is crazy so he's
there for a year
yeah now imagine this well the one guy
that he talks about this sergeant shows
up
his first day gets killed they don't
even know what his name is so
so here's a guy that's going 365 days
of front line someone else shows up and
they're dead
in an hour
yeah man i mean you can't i'm listening
to the book and i'm like bro this guy's
gonna die
soon you know obviously he doesn't die
but you get that's how it feels you know
it's like then he just keeps going back
that's crazy man um in the beginning it
had a
you know that graphic tale of the guts
yep you know
who does that to somebody
i can you know they obviously capture
them and they just
what cut them open and let their gu and
then hang them up like
how can you even do that yep
baffling beats well it's humans it's
human beings
guess right the the darkness
yeah but i don't know man no but
yeah i know but you know as far as like
our perspective you know how like
i guess maybe you could get talked
through it like
you know you hear about these crazy
things that people do right whether it
be to each other or whatever
and you kind of hear everything you're
like i can see how he got there i would
never do that kind of stuff but i can't
see how he got there you can kind of be
like i see i see
it's hard like that kind of stuff to be
like yeah this person we captured them
already i mean maybe certain
angry like if you're angry enough at
somebody maybe but
well what's interest here's a good
here's a good example of thought
processes
when he is when he gets
told hey go burn down that village yeah
and he goes no i'm not doing it yeah
now think about this he says i'm not
doing it and another guy's all right
i'll do it
so the other guy goes out to burn down
the village and he gets shot in the
chest and killed
and now you can see cap captain west is
like hey now do you want to go burn down
the village
and you would think you could he you
would think captain west is sort of
trying to take advantage of the anger
right right that you would have every
year yeah like let's get some revenge
yeah and he goes no
so that's that shows what his character
is like
and again this the the idea of this
character and the reason i talk about it
a lot is when you see
when we get to what happens in vietnam
you there's a lot of
you know his character you have to try
and understand his character
because of accusations that are being
made in all different directions
it's yeah yeah
and it's weird too like any one of these
actions that he did is so far off the
charts
of what what what's it what's expected
yeah
like to to like a normal award writing
above and beyond
at with complete disregard for his own
safety like all those things yeah
that's that's what he's got going on
yeah
crazy man well
back to the path well i was gonna say
speaking of human nature we know that
we as humans have a tendency
to drift off the path that's true so
maybe we need a little
nudge yeah well you know a wise man once
said
um it's hard to stay on the path
and once you slip off it may seem hard
to get back on
yeah but you can do it yep what do you
recommend
oh well there's good news because you're
not alone on the path
it might feel like it but you got some
help see what i'm saying help through
supplementation yep i said it so
okay so you uh we're working out that's
a big one
we already know that it it helps every
element of your life not just getting in
shape
being in shape it's funny i keep getting
reminded and i think i mentioned this
before
obviously i'm not going to go too deep
into it because it really pales in
comparison to
pretty much anything we've ever talked
about ever but
it doesn't mean you carry groceries very
close so
you know the water jugs right i said i
told you about this similar similar
situation but same thought process so
you know water jugs right
the big five gallon ones you put on the
cooler and stuff like that so i was
replacing mine at home
and you got bayonetted no no
that snapped off in your chest no i did
not get white phosphorus burning you to
the bone i did not
but i had to grab it off like this shelf
that was kind of high
see row and you put it like that you're
going to take away the juice oh where as
you left up you got shot
and the bullet wrapped around your bones
no no bullets hit me actually that day
but
i so i brought and the thing is like
what like 40 pounds
i think it's like eight pounds per
gallon right yeah i think so
anyway so 40 pounds boom and i and you
have to kind of let it drop
and
so you can't just like i did it with one
hand because i had something else in my
hand because i was doing some other
stuff at the same time
so it drops and i swing it almost like a
kettlebell you know you gotta catch the
momentum and
swing it and boom and boom 40 pound big
thing too by the way
so i bring it up and i'm walking with it
in one hand and i think i forget what i
had in the other hand i was doing
something else
and i walked it over and i was thinking
to myself
it's kind of good to have this kid
you're over here making like making the
comparison even more contrasty so it's
making it like sound all lame
but no when you think about it for sure
i'm telling you when you think about it
it's way better to have that capability
than not to you seems
to be able to handle the 40 pound
thing under like i don't want to say
harder circumstances but harder than
normal you see what i'm saying yeah
it's almost like you know having to grab
a wounded major
as you're being overrun and having to
throw him over your shoulder good point
right okay
that's that capability yes yes or just
keep a water jug from
or whatever okay perfect so that's the
point
the point is hey sometimes you gotta why
do you do this to yourself
you're doing it to me i'm not doing it
you're doing it you're just pointing out
what every single other person is
thinking
anyway if you gotta save somebody
you know and you gotta put them on your
shoulder yeah and run them
yep whether it be across the street or
whatever
it's good to have that capability rather
than oh shoot i can't do it by myself i
could ask for help
same thing check same thing with the
water jug check
if someone needs some help like hey you
know you know the kind your grandma or
whatever's like hey can you help me can
you grab that
thing up there you know the water jug
from on the shelf
you want to be the guy that they asked
to help because they know you can do it
you see what i'm saying yes bro hey look
i'll let you out of this here's your
outfit we're not in korea you can carry
on
here's your out you can take it hey man
i totally respect that you want to help
grandma yeah and whoever else needs help
and that's not to mention when you're by
yourself you don't gotta ask for help
because you can do it i'm saying okay
i'm just saying if you have that option
like it's better to choose option where
you have that capability is what i'm
saying i agree so
that's why one of the many infinite
reasons why working out is
important okay
i'm correct on that one you are correct
anyway when you're working out sometimes
you get little
little pains in your joints
which is no problem
that would induce pain as well for sure
for sure but
no worries jacob's supplements for these
things not the bayonet thing obviously
but you know
little pains in your joints and that
kind of stuff joint warfare
it's called joint warfare super krill
oil
i think pretty much people know what we
have hey check this out if you want some
of this stuff
which you should yeah
you if you subscribe to it
because you don't want to miss it if you
don't want to miss kriller you don't
want to miss joint warfare you don't
want to miss
you know what like you don't want to run
low on whatever
supplementation is making you strong is
giving you that freaking capability if
needed
to catch
i mean this could be a bag of groceries
this could be you know a
cantaloupe rolling off the counter and
you want to be you don't want your
joints to hurt as that's happening right
this could be
mayhem yeah this could be mayhem okay
see
and you subscribe then shipping is free
which is cool so okay okay so you you i
kind of shy away from assuming everybody
already knows
but you bring up a good point from time
to time that
what if like eighty-five percent of
people already know see i'm saying yeah
and then i'm like okay i'm accommodating
the other the the you know the fifteen
percent and kinda in a way
in a way kind of ignoring the 85 percent
the needs
of the 85 percent could be seen making
them go for that right as well
yeah no matter how good or bad that
right is yeah yeah exactly right right
now let's face it that ride is not fun
it's bumpy it's a bumpy ride yeah i
understand i understand
what else so we got joint warfare krill
oil
discipline discipline go molk what else
anything else
where are your kids or your kid milk
some vitamin d in there hey
so here's the here's actually the thing
here's here's an effective thing for the
85 percent of us who
do already know estimated go to
jackalful.com boom everything on there
choose like what you want you want the
additional protein boom grab that one
you want the joints off boom grab that
one you want a dessert you want a
dessert
that happens to have that protein in it
nonetheless yeah so yes uh jackalful.com
the discipline
go energy drink scenario
these you can get of course the
jockeyfield.com but you can get them at
wawa
vitamin shop yep yep
there you go there you go
also what a vitamin chop yes also origin
main or origin usa
yeah look at that yourself yeah well you
know
um origin usa.com that's where you can
get the stuff as well
but you can also get or should i say you
will notice
when you're on there that you can also
get american made
jeans boots jiu-jitsu stuff as in geez
geez rash guard gee bags
yeah some good stuff on there check
check i like it
it's true also
chocolate store it's called jocko store
that's where you can get discipline
equals freedom
stuff you get hardcore recondo stuff
stuff it's true
it's very i need more of those shirts by
the way and more of these shirts by the
way all right you got it i know the guy
and the
x flat can hook you up for with the
discount and everything it's a flag
all good also if you were attacking a
an enemy position and it was flying this
flag would you hesitate a little bit
more
i think i would you would induce some
hesitation you would look at this flag
and you'd say
wait a second these people look like
they are gonna bring the heat
yeah they look like they have discipline
everything ever goes like crazy in this
country
or in the world you will see me like
let's say
revolution war civil war whatever
whatever
whatever mayhem mm-hmm i'll be flying
this flag
well yeah that's what you find symbol of
discipline
yeah yeah good idea i'll join your your
thing what do you mean you just don't
get to join because you want to
i've i have capability and i'm highly
trained if i need someone to catch the
water bottles we're good to go
i will be an asset to your team anyway
dropstore.com
there's a cool uh scenario on there
called the shirt locker that's
if you want a new designed shirt
did you ever get props to the guy that
came up with shirt locker
on twitter was it on twitter oh directly
no i have nuts yeah so whoever you are
mystery
human good job you know did you see it
or did i see it
you did it yeah you told me that i told
you about it yeah that's a mystery humor
i was gonna blame you
you should have tracked his name but you
didn't yeah it wasn't even you that did
it
see blaming never works no my fault it's
okay
jack nonetheless that is what's going on
on jocklestar.com so yeah check it out
if you like something get something
it's a good spot also subscribe to this
podcast if you want to
sure if you haven't yet if you just
listen to three hours and you haven't
subscribed yet
that's your choice but if you want to
provide a little bit of support you can
subscribe to it you can
leave a review sure oh yeah
we also have some other podcasts we have
jocko unraveling new episodes out
daryl cooper from martyr maid we have
the grounded podcast
we have new warrior kid podcasts
amazing yes we prioritized and executed
on those
yeah actually uncle jake came through on
those ones because they're actually
they're
pretty good very check jack
you don't have to legitimately good made
an adjustment there uh new warrior kid
podcast you can check those out also we
have the
the uh the the jocko underground
podcast which is some amplifying
information some
behind the scenes kind of kind of we've
got some q a stuff coming if you're a
member of
the undergrad if you're a member of
jackonunderground.com you can
actually ask questions and
yeah go to jockowunderground.com if you
want to
what's it subscribe you have to pay
money
well you pretty much have to pay when
it's eight dollars and 18 cents a month
a bunch of reasons why we're doing it
we're doing it because we don't want to
actually have somebody
injecting uh
advertisements into the middle of the
podcast
we don't want to have that so there you
go
you can pay and if you can't afford it
look we're not trying to hold back
information
if you can't afford it no problem no
factor if you can't afford to eight
dollars and eighteen cents a month email
assistance jocko underground.com
and uh we also have a youtube channel
which where echo like he just
he he bludgeons us with videos
what are you even talking about i'm just
talking about how some of the videos
that that
you that you're solely responsible for a
lot of people don't like them
fish no brad it's not a fish but yeah
it's official verified how about that
yes verified also check out origin usa
they're putting up stuff if you want to
know the story that's happening up there
and there's zero explosions in their
stuff whereas and there's a very limited
number of explosions
on long videos yeah what charles makes
origin usa that's main thai
right that's main thai yeah yeah he's
hooking that up he's doing some good
work up there
you approve of me very much doesn't make
anything explode
well we're we're working on that but he
doesn't have the skills
skill set steps maybe it's because he
maybe it's because he is
uses some discretion when he make his
videos yeah
very possible yeah
jack all right there we go it's getting
late
also psychological warfare if you don't
know what that is
it's an album with tracks so when you
hit moments of weakness you got jockey
to help you
just realize since i just got done with
the warrior kid i just realized
probably a year ago i said oh make some
more psychological warfare for everybody
i haven't done it dang yeah well
you gotta kind of collect or think of or
kind of mentally get uh
like current weaknesses the thing is
though is people like people were so
stoked on that
on that album and gave such good
feedback
and i think i was just like oh yeah well
people were asking like hey can you do
one for us tonight and i didn't really
i was like pumped you know and then the
prioritizing excuse me oh damn
started to start other things started
i was gonna say what'd you lose
motivation on that one
well motivation isn't going to get it
there you go
literally motivation will not get that
only discipline
maybe i need to make a maybe i need to
make a
psychological warfare track of what to
do when you don't feel like making a
psychological warfare
second album exactly right exactly uh
check flipside canvas flipsidecampus.com
dakota meyer
my brother who's making cool stuff to
hang on your wall got a bunch of books
got a novel coming out but maybe it's a
novel we're not really sure what it is
but i wrote something that's not a
leadership book and it's not a kid's
book
it's a story
well we'll say that for now i think i'll
read a little some of it
some at some point so
the book is called final spin you can
pre-order it right now and you can get
that first
dish uh leadership strategy tactics
field manual
the code the evaluation the protocols
discipline equals freedom field manual
the way the warrior kid
four field man well i just tapped out my
mic right there sorry about that echo
challenge you have to
fix that in post okay weigh the world
kid four
field manual weigh the word get one two
three mike in the dragons about face by
hackworth extreme
ownership dichotomy leadership echelon
front leadership consultancy
we solve problems through leadership go
to ashlandfront.com
if you need help inside your
organization we do live
training all the time and we have
courses
online available efonline.com if you
want to check that out
we have some live events that we're
doing
called the muster the muster
go to extremeownership.com if you want
to come to the muster
we also have ef battlefield coming up
we've sold one out
and so now we're going to see if we're
going to do one more if you want to
learn lessons from the battle of
gettysburg if you want to walk the
if you want to walk the battlefield and
and see where general lee and longstreet
and ap
hill and general meade and and and
colonel joshua chamberlain
you come to that spot on little round
top where joshua
chamberlain and the 20th maine talking
about
bayonet charge down the hill you can you
can go there and you will
feel it so go to echelonfront.com
events if you want to come to that we
already sold out the first part it's
only
like it's 35 people per so
it's two days you me
35 of you 35 of us 36 of us
whatever so come and check that out if
you want to help service members if you
want to help
active duty and retired service members
if you want to help their families if
you want to help gold star families
check out mark lee's mom she's got a
charity
organization mama lee and if you want to
donate or you want to get involved
go to america's mightywarriors.org
and if you want more of my weary some
readings or you need more of
echo's uncoupled inquires
increase you can find us on the
interwebs on twitter on instagram
when just so echo knows what i'm talking
about he only knows that
as the gram and on
that
and thanks to all the people out there
in uniform
maintaining our proud our proud
traditions of military service
as you also protect our way of life and
to our police and law enforcement and
firefighters and paramedics and emts and
dispatchers and correctional officers
and border patrol and secret service and
all first responders
thank you for protecting us as well
and everyone else remember what colonel
anthony
herbert's father told him
before he left for boot camp
he said nothing is as hard
as just getting started
don't wait don't hesitate don't ponder
anymore
just get started
and until next time this is echo and
jocko
out